by case basis for those fleeing certain
totalitarian or communist regimes in our
hemisphere at the same time it has made
clear that our borders are not open and
those arriving outside lawful Pathways
will be sent home recent deportation and
removal numbers reflect that hard
reality for many
unlike its predecessor the Biden
Administration is enforcing border and
immigration laws in an orderly humane
way consistent with precedence set by
Pride administrations of both parties
some may not like that but those are
policy differences and nothing more you
don't impeach a cabinet secretary
because you don't like their policies
and you certainly don't impeach a
cabinet secretary to appease extreme
members of your political party
secretary mayorkas is fulfilling his
duty under the law and to the American
people if the Republican majority
doesn't like what he's doing they should
work with Democrats to pass bipartisan
border security and immigration reform
legislation
apparently they prefer a political
theater and sloppy inaccurate quote
unquote report instead
Mr chairman I yield back thank you
ranking member other members of the
committee are reminded that opening
statements may be submitted to the
record and I'd like without objection to
enter into the record the DHS order of
secession which shows that Mr Wolf had
the authority to serve as secretary
without objection so ordered
I'm pleased to have a distinguished
panel of witnesses before us today on
this overdue discussion I ask that our
Witnesses please rise and raise their
right hand
do you solemnly swear that the testimony
you will give before the committee on
homeland security of the United States
House of Representatives will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you God
let the record reflect that the
witnesses have answered in the
affirmative
please be seated you none okay I'd like
to now formally introduce the witnesses
Mr Chad Wolfe serves as America First
policy institute's executive director
Chief strategy officer and the chair for
the center of Homeland Security and
immigration prior to joining afpi Mr
Wolf was the former acting Secretary of
the U.S Department of Homeland Security
during his time at DHS he successfully
navigated numerous Global and domestic
challenges to the nation's security
including covid-19 civil unrest numerous
border and immigrations crises historic
national disasters and threats to Global
Aviation Security
prior to his Services DHS he spent over
10 years in the private sector helping
clients manage risks and before that
worked here on Capitol Hill he has
received the U.S Secretary of
Transportation 911 911 metal the U.S
Secretary of Homeland Security
distinguished service medal and the
National Intelligence distinguished
service medal Mr Joe edlow
has an extensive distinguished
background in Immigration policy he most
recently served as acting director of
U.S citizenship and Immigration Services
prior to that position he served as the
chief counsel for USCIS
before his time at USCIS Mr edlow worked
on immigration issues in various
capacities under the Trump
Administration including with the
Executive Office of the President and
the Justice Department's office of legal
policy he served from 2008 to 2015 as
assistant chief counsel for the U.S
Immigration and Customs Enforcement he
possesses significant experience on
Capitol Hill as well including stents
with the house Judiciary Committee and
former representative Raul Labrador of
Idaho
Mr Rodney Scott is a law enforcement
officer and the former Chief of the
United States border patrol where he
served from January 2020 to August 2021
under both president Trump and President
Biden Scott has served in the border
patrol and CBP since 1992. throughout
his career Mr Scott held roles such as
assistant chief and cbp's office of
anti-terrorism in Washington D.C as well
as the division Chief and director for
The Incident Management and operations
coordination division at CBP
headquarters Miss Eleanor Acer is a
senior director for Refugee protection
at Human Rights first where she oversees
human rights firsts research and
advocacy on issues relating to Refugee
protection Asylum and the human rights
of migrants Ms Acer served on the
American Bar association's Commission on
immigration as the vice chair of the
refugee Council USA from 2006 to 2008
and currently serves on its board Ms
Acer received her JD from Fordham
University School of Law under ba in
history from Brown University
I thank all the witnesses for being here
today and I now recognize Mr Wolf for
five minutes to summarize his opening
statement chairman Greene representative
Thompson thank you again for the
opportunity to testify today by any
objective measure or metric the U.S is
facing the worst humanitarian and
National Security crisis along our
Southern Border in our nation's history
today's border secure security system is
unrecognizable from the America First
policies of the Trump Administration or
even those in place during previous
Administrations
in all Candor this is the first
administration of either political party
to deliberately take steps to diminish
the security along our Southern border
here's the situation along the border
today
this country has experienced the largest
mass scale Catch and Release policy that
has resulted in more than 4.5 million
illegal aliens including 1.5 million
known gotaways being allowed into
American communities
that is a population larger than every
major U.S city except for New York City
there have been more than 200 known or
suspected terrorists apprehended at the
southern border compared to just 11
during the Trump Administration
the border is effectively controlled by
the Mexican cartels fentanyl is coming
across the border in record amounts and
is the leading cause of death of Young
Americans more migrants have died during
their Journey than ever before
380 000 children and Counting have been
trafficked or smuggled across the
southern border and abused physically
mentally and in some cases sexually
along the horrendous journey in the last
two years this Administration has lost
contact with more than 85 000 children
after releasing them to sponsors many of
them unvetted and tens of thousands of
children have been subjected to
indentured servitude and harsh forced
labor situations
and lastly we are seeing a concerted
effort to facilitate illegal aliens into
the country at ports of Entry through an
unlawful parole program in a cbp-1 app
to disguise or otherwise hide the extent
of the crisis from the American people
I understand the difficulty and
complexity of running the Department of
Homeland Security but it is clear to me
and to millions of Americans that this
is a crisis by Design and one that was
avoidable
I'm here today as a veteran of DHS
having served at the department in two
presidential administrations spanning
over seven years holding eight senior
level positions that culminated in
serving as the acting secretary but
perhaps most importantly earning the
respect of the Department's law
enforcement officials along the way
and while I look forward to today's
discussion as you have already heard
some members will choose to attack me
because I am critical of the
administration's actions surrounding
this crisis
this is what you will likely hear
this is what you have heard they will
claim I ignored a subpoena to appear
before this Committee in 2020. what they
have failed to provide you is the
relevant context that I gave this
committee over two months of dates for
that hearing and for my availability and
that a hearing was never scheduled or
that it would have been improper for me
to testify after president Trump
nominated me to be DHS secretary
it will attack me because of questions
surrounding the Department's order of
succession and how it affected my role
as acting secretary a role that I am
very proud of
to the extent they mentioned policies
they will fixate over a short-lived Zero
Tolerance from five years ago while
staling completely silent about the
historic and ongoing migrant child
trafficking crisis facilitated by this
Administration
the reason we see a border in crisis in
crisis and chaos is simple
the Biden Administration has dismantled
all of the proven and effective policies
put in place under the last
Administration that includes well-known
policies like the remain in Mexico and
the Asylum Cooperative agreements with
the northern triangle but it also
includes more than two dozen
lesser-known but effective policies such
as a third country Transit Asylum bar a
humanitarian Asylum review process a
prompt a Salem claim Asylum claim review
a regulation to end fake families in the
cruel recycling of Migrant children
having border patrol agents conduct
credible fear screenings internal
relocation guidance expedited removal
ending Nationwide Catch and Release
maxing out ice detention capacity and
exceeding annual deportation targets and
the list goes on and every one of those
have been torn down
by comparison this Administration has
embraced ineffective and unlawful
policies that have made American
communities dangerous and have enriched
the Mexican cartels
these policies include a nationwide
Catch and Release scheme that
incentivizes millions and millions of
other illegal aliens to enter illegally
a 100-day deportation freeze for all
illegal aliens including criminals
releasing illegal aliens on an honor
System just self-report to ice field
offices
exempting 99 percent of the illegal
aliens from deportation the lowest level
of ice detention capacity lowest
deportations in modern history
terminating remaining Mexico and fully
exempting children from title 42.
this is dangerous and this is an
inhumane approach that need not occur
the laws did not change between
administrations just the decision by
this one not to follow the laws
the reason cited here and others I'm
happy to discuss it is my professional
opinion that this Administration is
derelict in its duty to Faithfully
execute the laws as written and protect
American communities thank you and I
look forward to your questions
I now recognize Mr edlow for five
minutes to summarize this opening
statement thank you chairman Greene
ranking member Thompson distinguished
members of this committee I appreciate
the opportunity to present testimony
today regarding the continuing threats
to the Integrity of our immigration
system caused by the secretary in the
Department of Homeland Securities
willful disregard of our country's
immigration laws
the Biden Administration through the
secretary has seen fit to ignore the law
instead favoring poorly conceived and
poorly executed policy decisions
actions through executive orders
departmental memos and rules lay waste
to the Ina and Congressional intent it
has eroded our immigration system and
propelled the crisis to current levels
as the chairman said Section 102 of the
Ina charges the Secretary of Homeland
Security with Administration and
enforcement of the act and further vests
in the secretary the power and duty to
control and guard the boundaries and
borders of the United States against the
illegal entry of aliens the massive
number of encounters recorded by CBP and
the small number of alien removals by
Ice however suggested this secretary has
failed to Faithfully execute the laws
entrusted to him
since day one of the administration the
department has taken aggressive action
to undermine immigration enforcement
nowhere is that clearer than secretary
mayorkas's September 30th 2021
memorandum outlining the appropriate
instances in which DHS was authorized to
take action against aliens either
unlawfully present or lawfully present
but removable
specifically secretary mayorkas outlined
three main buckets for removal threats
to National Security threats to Public
Safety and threats to border security
while in theory this would seem to
Encompass many aliens in reality the
numerous carve outs loose definitions
and required factors for consideration
made it nearly impossible for ice to
move forward with most enforcement
actions these poorly defined categories
gave even some of the most serious of
criminal aliens a free pass in the
interest of equity let me be clear there
is a time and a place for prosecutorial
discretion which has been recognized by
the Supreme Court
however memos targeted at whole groups
and not on a case-by-case basis do not
comply with Contours of such discretion
categorical prosecutorial discretion is
not discretion at all it is instead an
effort to undermine the enforcement
mechanisms clearly found in the law the
Department's failure to enforce the full
Ina in the name of prioritization and
discretion is a dereliction of Duty the
rampant parole abuse that we now witness
is exactly why Congress saw fit to
change the law in 1996 replacing
emergent reasons or for reasons deemed
strictly in the public interest with on
a case-by-case basis for humanitarian
reasons or significant public benefit
Congress signaled its intention to clamp
down on the process it specifically
wanted to guard against ad hoc programs
meant to supplement existing immigration
programs regardless of the plain
language as it currently stands parole
has become a favorite tool of the
administration while first uses an
alternative to detention parole programs
have subsequently played a large role in
artificially decreasing border numbers
the extended the expanded categorical
parole programs for Nationals of
Venezuela Cuba Nicaragua and Haiti are
wholly unlawful
while certainly the previous
administration utilized programs the
number of Parolees were a small fraction
compared to what we have seen on a
monthly basis over the past two and a
half years
I would be remiss if I did not mention
the Department's regulatory agenda which
seeks to upend the credible fear process
in the name of orderly processing
starting with the presumption that every
economic migrant is entitled to
protection in 2022 DHS issued an interim
final rule on incredible fear screening
under the new process a positive
credible fear determination by an asylum
officer will lead to a non-adversarial
Asylum interview before another DHS
Asylum officer this impermissibly
changes the process and undermines
congressional action by shifting
adjudication Authority from doj to DHS
even more concerning written summary of
the original Credible fear interview now
doubles as an aliens Asylum application
rendering moot the requirement that an
alien file one at all this shifts the
burden to present and prepare a
meritorious claim for protection while
this does not ensure an asylum Grant it
certainly provides a path for fraud and
renders certain anti-asylum fraud
measures moot
a second final rule issued last month
appears to be tough on illegal border
crossers making them ineligible for
Asylum however the number of exceptions
and the easily rebuttable presumptions
belie its stated purpose this rule will
have the opposite effect as it will
ultimately incentivize aliens to make
the dangerous Trek northward with
families in tow
Mr chairman we would not be sitting here
today if the secretary in the department
simply enforced the law as written
instead the department has in an effort
to remove barriers and to create a
subjectively orderly system conflated
law and policy and ensured that when the
two were in conflict that policy won the
day a return to the rule of law is the
only cure at this point and is incumbent
upon Congress to use its oversight and
lawmaking authority to repair the Damage
Done by the department thank you and I
look forward to your questions
thank you Mr edlow I now recognize Mr
Scott for five minutes to summarize his
opening statement
chairman Greene remember rinky member
Thompson members of the committee thank
you for letting me testify here today
the career professionals at DHS and
specifically Customs and Border
Protection and U.S border Patrol deserve
our praise and admiration I am confident
that they are doing everything they can
every day to protect this country
despite this administration's efforts to
undermine their efforts the chaos at our
Southwest border and the consequences
are a result of actions taken by the
Biden Administration the perspectives
that I provide are grounded in my
professional experience including my
time as Chief in the Biden
Administration
Decades of bipartisan border security
improvements were erased on January 20th
2021 when the Biden Administration
announced actions that they that were
heard around the world as the U.S
borders are now open
as predicted the most secure border the
U.S had ever enjoyed disintegrated into
chaos the by administration's claims
that they inherited a border in shambles
that surges an illegal immigration like
this are normal or that allowing more
illegal aliens to go through a Port of
Entry is solving the problem are not
accurate the crisis at our border is
still raging don't get lulled into
believing that 3 500 arrests a day
should be cheered just because it is
lower than the 11 000 a day we saw a few
weeks ago
the border patrol remains overwhelmed
the cartels continue to control who and
what is entering the United States
migrants are still being exploited and
children are still being trafficked CBP
has recorded over 6 million encounters
and over 1.4 million known godaways
that's under the bite Administration but
numbers failed to convey the severity of
the National Security consequences
some consequences are easier to measure
than others before a bomb goes off the
1.4 million known gotaways are a
measurable consequence of Agents being
overwhelmed but consider that hundreds
of miles of Border lack any persistent
surveillance and when construction of
the border wall system was terminated
the associated technology was also
terminated
every minute that agents are not
patrolling the U.S border increases the
probability of more known I'm sorry more
unknown gotaways
most illicit narcotics including the
fentanyl that is readily available in
your hometown originated outside of the
United States
every agent and officer taken away from
inspection and Patrol duties decreases
our nation's ability to interdict these
poisons before they can hurt your family
your friends and your neighbors
leaving hundreds of miles of Border
unmanned and unpatrolled
is like leaving the doors of your home
open when you go on vacation
you can replace things that get stolen
but the real threat is the unknown
person hiding in your home and you
return
verifying any unknown person's Identity
or their story requires a face-to-face
conversation
how many human trafficking incidents
went undetected because our law
enforcement Personnel today are being
instructed to process aliens like a fast
food drive-through
how do we quantify the intelligence
collection opportunities that were lost
additionally when CBP officers are
redirected to conduct immigration and
processing legal trade and travel
suffers this further disrupts our supply
chain
increases the cost of imported goods
and more as chief of the United States
border patrol my staff and I engaged and
advised the Biden transition teams well
before inauguration the administration's
laser focus on Expediting processing and
increasing opportunities for migrants to
enter the U.S never wavered advice from
career professionals was ignored
policies were implemented that resulted
resulted in thousands of aliens being
released into the U.S illegal
immigration intensified overwhelmed
border patrol and effectively
transferred control of our Southwest
border directly to the Mexican drug
cartels
this is a national security threat
cartels use illegal aliens to overwhelm
law enforcement creating controllable
gaps in border security these gaps are
exploited to smuggle anything they want
into the United States to think that
terrorist networks and hostile nations
are not exploiting this vulnerability is
naive
I'm not here testifying about policy
differences policy is how you carry out
your duties under the law the Secretary
of Homeland Security has a legal duty to
prevent the illegal entry of aliens and
to secure our border even if success is
untainable he still needs to try instead
secretary Marcus has chosen to expend
Department resources to provide care for
aliens that enter the U.S illegally
as detailed in my written testimony I
believe the secretary is derelict in his
duties to secure the border and I also
believe that the secretary has likely
violated the empowerment Control Act
secretary mayorkas is great it under
invoking understandable compassion for
the apply to the migrants and I too
acknowledge our humanitarian
responsibilities
but as Secretary of the United States
Department of Homeland Security
and the overseer of billions of tax
dollars that are appropriated to protect
America if you look at that this
Administration is clearly not doing
their job
thank you Mr Scott I now recognize Acer
for five minutes to summarize her
opening statement
thank you chairman Greene ranking member
Thompson and distinguished members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify before you today
over the last few years human rights
first has documented the horrific harms
inflicted on people due to the remain in
Mexico and title 42 policies I
personally witnessed the first days of
the implementation of remain in Mexico
from Tijuana under the Trump
Administration
and the final days of the title 42
policy from Matamoros and Reynosa last
month
my testimony focuses on a few key areas
first are laws and treaties rightly
allow people seeking protection from
persecution to seek Asylum an asylum is
both morally just and politically
popular
second not only did Trump Administration
policies like remain in Mexico and title
42 evade and violate Refugee law but
they spurred chaos and inflicted massive
human suffering
third the Biden Administration should
swiftly end its Asylum ban which
endangers the lives of refugees and is
inconsistent with the law as were the
Trump administration's bans on Asylum
fourth as human rights firsts experts on
extremism and anti-Semitism have
detailed rhetoric painting migrants and
Asylum Seekers as threats or Invaders
fuels white supremacist conspiracy
theories and violence it must be
countered
finally Congress and the Biden
Administration should work together to
implement effective strategies and
provide the necessary resources to
address challenges at the border and
properly staff safe effective fare
Asylum adjudications
the crisis we're facing is a
humanitarian one and it's global
in my written testimony I outline the
ways in which human rights situations
have deteriorated in countries in the
Americas including Cuba Guatemala Haiti
Nicaragua and Venezuela pushing people
to flee in search of protection safety
and stability the reality is that the
vast majority of the world's refugees
are hosted by other countries and here
in the Americas other countries are
hosting refugees as well
six million of the 7.1 million
Venezuelans who have fled are hosted in
countries in Latin America and the
Caribbean
the United States is more than capable
of humanely receiving and fairly
processing the claims of people seeking
Refuge here
under the Trump Administration human
rights first tracked
1544 reports of kidnappings murder
torture rape and other violent attacks
against people returned to Mexico under
MPP
and during the court-ordered
re-implementation of MPP in 2022
Asylum Seekers continued to be targeted
and PP hearings remained a due process
farce many Asylum Seekers were abducted
while traveling through border regions
to attend hearings or directly outside
U.S ports of Entry before or after their
hearings MPP also wasted government
resources dhs's analysis concluded it
diverted resources from other migration
priorities
in June 2020 the Supreme Court confirmed
the DHS secretary had authority to end
the policy
Asylum Seekers and migrants returned to
Mexico under title 42 similarly suffered
kidnappings rapes and other attacks the
Trump Administration Inc returned
well-known political activists from
Nicaragua directly back to their country
of persecution
human rights first has tracked over 13
480 reports of kidnappings torture and
other attacks against Asylum Seekers and
migrants during the Biden Administration
moreover far from being an effective
border management tool the policy
actually spurred increased Crossings
between ports of Entry inflated border
apprehension statistics and exacerbated
cartel violence ending title 42 does not
mean that the U.S border is open it
means U.S immigration Refugee law can no
longer be evaded by specious invocation
of Public Health Authority
the Biden Administration has taken
important steps towards expanding
Refugee resettlement from the Americas
and some regular Pathways to the U.S
through parole
as outlined in my testimony the
Department of Homeland Security has
Authority legal authority to parole
individuals into the country and legal
authority to release people from
detention
the use of these legal legal authorities
do not mean the border is open
in conclusion the Biden Administration
and Congress should work together to
uphold Refugee law at U.S borders
maximizing Asylum at ports of Entry
after years of blockage is essential
to end the counterproductive
consequences of term policies that
restricted and blocked access to Asylum
at ports of entry and pushed populations
to cross between
we should enhance support for Refugee
hosting capacities in other countries
support for strong Asylum systems and
reception capacities ramp up speed up
and strengthen Regional resettlement
improve parole and other safe migration
policies Implement humanitarian rather
than punitive approaches to Refugee
protection
and take other steps that I've outlined
in detail in my testimony
we also need to press the Biden
Administration to end its Asylum ban and
to stop subjecting Asylum Seekers to
fast-track processing in CBB custody as
the Trump Administration did thank you
so much
thank you for your testimony and I now
recognize myself for questions
um I want to talk about this claim that
there's been a 70 decrease
you know since title 42 went away
um and it looks like they're they're
counting the encounters at 3 500
compared to the peak of 11 000. the the
the actual record number which happened
right before that but what they're not
counting it's very interesting confirm I
don't know any of the witnesses that can
confirm this but
um that we're not counting the CBP one
app appointments as I understand it is
that correct
that is correct so the numbers that are
being cited by the department are border
patrol numbers those are encounters
between ports of Entry so they talk
about uh I believe a 70 decrease what
they're not telling you they're actually
capturing the number but they're not
including in their press release is the
number from ofo which is the office of
field operations they're at a Port of
Entry are the number of inadmissibles
that are showing up at ports of entry
and what's happening is they're being
shifted between the ports of Entry it's
a show it's a shell game basically we're
taking the numbers out of these and
we're not reporting them over here and
we're allowing for appointments to be
made through CBP one app and then saying
that that's a lawful mechanism of Entry
Mr edlow is the is that in congruence
with the law
is that a lawful entry just because you
fill out a a an app online no no it's
not so it's a violation of the law it's
a violation and and frankly if somebody
comes to the Port of Entry has no uh
documentation to get in there is a
lawful mechanism for them to claim
credible fear and to move through that
process but to just allow them to come
in to parole them uh not on a
case-by-case basis I might add but as a
group uh it is not within the confines
of that it's it's against the laws
passed by the United States Congress
okay uh so again kind of digging into
this a little a little further
this group of and I think the amount of
the appointments are about 1500 or so a
day add that to the 3500 add that to the
number that don't schedule an
appointment and come through that we
don't know that number because they're
not reporting that number they're really
been an appreciable decrease in your
opinions uh since uh the beginning since
title 42 went away
I do not I do not believe that there has
been a decrease in the numbers it is a
shell game and the other thing I want to
point out too is it's very selective
about what day they choose to Compare
the numbers to you need to look at a
little broader amount of time the border
for for my entire career was
systematically getting more and more
controlled and we are actually driving
those numbers down you have to look at
it longer not just one day in time
Mr Wolf on May 10th reporter and
immigration analyst Todd as benjman
reported ahead of the expiration of
title 42 that Mexican immigration
officials were informing him that they
were coordinating with DHS Personnel on
the other side of the border to move
illegal aliens from the Mexico side of
the Rio Grande to the American side in
other words they were helping aliens
illegally cross into the United States
this would violate as I understand it
section 274 of the Ina which prohibits
aiding and abetting illegal immigration
or helping someone enter the country and
your opinion would such an intentional
coordination on a high-profile stage
have been conducted without the approval
or foreknowledge of the Secretary of
Homeland Security no you would need to
have approval up and down the chain of
command
so basically again violating the laws of
the United States you you think that
Authority I mean the border patrol guys
would never do that without the
authority of the secretary is that what
you're saying
it's hard for me to say whether uh the
border patrol the chief of the Border
Patrol was aware uh or whether that made
it all the way to the secretary or not I
I'm not there so I can't I can't testify
to that I can't imagine they'd willfully
break the law without the secretary
giving them approval but that we'll dig
further into that later
um the interim final rule that came out
Mr edlow can you discuss a little bit
about how this uh basically upends the
entire intent to the laws of Congress
from the Ina certainly Mr chairman uh
the when the Homeland Security Act was
uh was signed and enacted in in
2002-2003 most powers that had been
exercised by the former ins were moved
over to the new DHS specifically with
Asylum to USCIS where Asylum officers
were conducting interviews however after
a credible fear interview the the way it
always had worked was that it would the
the alien would then go before the
immigration judge that powers were never
transferred as part of the Homeland
Security Act this rule does transfer
does shift that Authority from doj to
DHS having a second bite at the Apple uh
to uh feed people into the country
basically not have to correct the
immigration judge process not only that
that sir but the fact that they do not
uh require a new Asylum application
really does uh limit the ability for
anyone to assess whether there's a valid
claim or not my time has expired I yield
to the ranking member
thank you very much uh
uh Mr chairman Miss ASA Republicans have
constantly falsely accused Secretary
mayorkas of Ben derelict and his duty to
secure the Border even though as I said
in my opening statement border
encounters have dropped sharply since
the Biden Administration terminated
Tower 42 last months Republicans don't
like the Biden Administration is
returning to a more orderly Humane
border and immigration policy after the
cruelty and dysfunction of the Trump
Administration and they can't stand that
these policies have been affected so we
are seeing this political theater play
out uh with the Republican leadership
trying desperately to appease its
members my Republican colleagues seem to
be particularly upset about the Biden
Administration allowing people to
present themselves at poor entry to seek
Asylum as provided under the law just as
every other administration had prior to
this one actually there seems to be some
revisionist history going on because
even president Trump's Secretary of
Homeland Security Kristen Nielsen Mr
Wolf's former boss acknowledged in fact
encouraged migrants to come to Ports of
entry for processing saying and I quote
so if a migrant comes to a Port of Entry
they haven't broken any laws this is
exactly why we tried to encourage the
migrants to go to a Port of Entry the
Biden Administration is being sued to
force it to do more to restore access to
Asylum after the last administration's
effectively cut it off now miss Acer
since you're an immigration attorney
with vast experience and expertise in
this field I want to talk with you and
set the record straight
claiming Asylum at a Port of Entry is
lawful correct absolutely
claiming Asylum after being encountered
by border patrol is lawful too correct
absolutely yes
patrolling migrants
paroling migrants is lawful and within
the authority of the Secretary of
Homeland Security correct yes sir
no Administration has ever detained
everyone encountered at the border isn't
that right that is right
and that includes the Trump
Administration correct absolutely so
title 42 caused terrible harm to Asylum
Seekers which you saw firsthand on your
visits to the Border Town 42 was also
detrimental to border security isn't
that right absolutely please explain
that to the committee
as I mentioned in my testimony title 42
encouraged repeat entries it did not
have immigration consequences it also
pushed populations that used to go and
seek Asylum at ports of Entry to end up
having to cross between ports of Entry
because not just for weeks but for
months and months and years and years
there was no way to actually cross the
border the change the the change in
numbers we've seen I believe is a
confirmation of what an absolute
disaster title 42 was from so many ways
Asylum Seekers that we met at the border
were trying to use the CBP one app and
and how that works for those of you who
who haven't seen it is it people provide
information that the government receives
and actually reviews in advance one of
our concerns about the cbp1 app is that
it could be used to actually meter and
limit the number of Asylum Seekers
allowed to legally seek Asylum in
addition uh I would say that you know
we're also concerned about Asylum
Seekers who are trying to approach ports
of Entry who are not being allowed to do
so now either because of CBP or Mexican
government authorities not letting them
do so
thank you uh
uh Mr chair I'd like to include in the
record uh a GAO decision that uh Mr Wolf
indeed served in that capacity uh of
secretary illegally uh I'd like to also
include uh a review requested by the
department and affirmed by GAO again
that Mr Wolf served in that capacity
illegally I'd also like to submit for
the record a fellow judge in Maryland
also ruled that Mr Wolf was serving
illegally in that position
without objection so ordered
Mr chairman we have an objection
object I don't believe the ranking
member was capable of presenting to this
committee justification for claiming
that that
secretary wolf served illegal this is
not a court of law it's a committee in
Congress object to the inclusion in the
historical record
okay
okay I I think we misunderstood the
gentleman's motion uh it was not
objection to the insertion of the
material into the record it was I think
just a statement of opinion about and so
uh so ordered the GAO reports are
entered into the record
I now recognize Mr McCall from Texas
chairman McCall from Texas for his five
minutes question thank you Mr chairman
you know I uh served as chairman of this
committee
for three terms now uh foreign affairs
committee and uh Mr edlow good to see
you we've worked together on these
issues and secretary wolf Mr Scott a
great state of Texas
um and I was a federal prosecutor
charged with
prosecutions at the border
um
political Asylum is always the magnet
and it is has been abused by the cartels
for many years
85 percent of these claims are not legit
only 15 percent are it's very simple
when they're allowed to enter the United
States because we don't have detention
space
they are released into our society
they're given a notice to appear
and they disappear and I've seen this
for 20 years in Congress in fact my
first bill was the in Catch and Release
and here we are today with the same
program
the Trump Administration
through secretary wolf Mr edlow
implemented what I thought was a very
effective Plan called the migrant
protection protocols
remain in Mexico
because it they had to remain in Mexico
pending their adjudication if it was
legitimate they were allowed in if not
they they were not allowed into the
country and it brought the numbers down
dramatically
so what happened with The Divide
Administration gets into power
nearly on day one secretary mayorkas
rescinds the order
where sins migrant protection protocols
remain in Mexico and what has happened
since then
nearly a hundred thousand young people
died in this country due to fentanyls
enough has come in to kill enough has
been seized to kill billions of people
five million encounters nearly a hundred
on the terror watch Lewis which used to
frighten me as chairman of this
committee when I would hear of anybody
on the terrorist watch us getting into
the United States of America
there was a
there was a court order
to force the administration to
re-implement NPP that court order in my
view has not been fully complied with by
this Administration
to make things worse they they took the
vetting process away from sponsors
of these aliens
what has that turned into
children going to houses 20 30 of them
under one sponsor not vetted turns into
a human trafficking Enterprise a
criminal Enterprise Young
girls being sex trafficked and young men
going to MS-13 as they try to pay back
the cartels cartels now are on operation
control when I was down at the border
after the recession of MPP I asked the
chief of Border Patrol
Mr Ortiz
is there a direct cause and effect
between the recession of this program
and what we're seeing at the border
totally out of chaos he told me the
answer was yes
and every border patrol officer will
tell you that because they live it in my
state Mr Scott as you know has spent 4.5
billion dollars just this session to
deal with this problem a federal
responsibility so Mike my question is
do you believe Mr Wolf Mr Scott Mr edlow
that secretary marork is is responsible
for the consequences that followed of
the rescission of MPP
and do you believe he is complicit
with the consequences of what has
happened to this country
so the answer to that is a resounding
yes obviously the secretary ended MPP
migrant protection protocols so he's
responsible for the actions that follow
that and I would just say look at the
end of the day it
it's okay to claim Asylum what's not
okay is to simply be released into the
country or it's not okay to say that
there's an immense amount of fraud in
the Asylum system DHS knows that they
have the numbers we all use the numbers
that come from DHS but they simply put
blinders on and say we're okay with that
amount of fraud it's okay for the
American people that's why we
implemented MPP and we did a number of
other things they're not doing any of
that now so all the folks that are
claiming a silent ports of Entry again
are being released into American
communities that's not okay I agree Mr
Scott Mr edlow
I agree fully and I want to point out
MPP made sure people got due process but
they did not get what they want most of
these people from my experience don't
really care about Asylum they don't
really care about the legal
documentation or process they want to be
released into the United States once
that was taken away the flow immediately
decreased because they couldn't commit
fraud everybody knew that this
Administration got rid of that program
intentionally they're responsible for
the results I'm sure it looked I I also
agree and there's plenty I could say
about MPP in terms of where it comes
from in terms of the Ina but I will just
say this when the court initially told
the secretary to reinstitute MPP there
was a there was an attempt to do that a
half-hearted attempt to do that but in
in the the press release that did that
it also made it clear that the secretary
had every intention to fight that
decision from the court and to take
measures to end MPP in other ways so it
was really never an actual attempt to to
reinstate it the gentleman's time is
expired I recognized Mr perea of
California
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to do
start out by submitting for the record
without objection the press release
mentioned by chairman Greene if I may
where it says that there were 10 1070
non-citizens processed on an average per
day via the CBP one app like to submit
this for records sir
that objection
Miss Acer does that sound like hiding
the data
no it's not hiding the data I want to
show you a quote by secretary Nielsen I
mean
so
we prefer Mr Wolf we prefer people
showing up at ports of Entry as opposed
to between ports of Entry yes no
absolutely I would say that is accurate
what I would say is that the migrants
are not making the law thank you very
much is breaking the law with the proof
you got other people you can address
here right just have three minutes left
or is it legal to come to Ports of Entry
absolutely
I want to show you a couple of pictures
here of the refugee challenge we have in
the Western Hemisphere
tell you the U.S is not number one
you've got other countries that are have
it even worse than we do right now
trying to address this human challenge
the world is facing I'm going to show
you also a picture of the Darion Gap and
a young girl who separated from her
mother
she's not coming to Disneyland
she's trying to survive
I'm gonna say Sir let me ask you
did secretary mayorkas create the
covid-19 pandemic
no sir
is he responsible for the unprecedented
violence gang violence extortion
assaults in Central America no sir how
about for the ongoing crisis in Haiti no
the economic instability in Venezuela no
human rights violations in Cuba
absolutely not
responsible for repression poverty in
Nicaragua
no instability in Peru nope Central
American economic crisis no sir China's
economic challenges absolutely not
Russian Ukrainian War and the ensuing
refugees from Ukraine and Russia no sir
African economic instability and food
shortages no
America's stunning economic growth
strongest in the world
no probably not
America's low unemployment rate
no
America's insatiable demand for workers
with or without documents no
responsible for the private sector
Farmers ranchers hiring of undocumented
workers no sir
let's just clarify Ms Acer is Asylum
legal yes
is it is approaching our ports of entry
and asking for Asylum is that legal
absolutely is that legal under
international law
absolutely
thank you very much I just want to add
the majority party here voted to end the
covid-19 health care emergency
and in doing so you lifted the lit you
they wanted to lift title 42.
what was left secretary mayorkas has
managed
he Enlisted the help of our neighbors no
other time in the history of the U.S and
Mexico has we have we had such a great
work in relationship with Mexico and the
others through Central and South America
on the issue of the refugee crisis so to
say that secretary mayorkas has been
derelict of his duty is misleading the
American people and presenting
misleading facts
Miss Acer is Mr mayorkas lying to the
American people
uh no sir I don't believe to my
knowledge though I do disagree with him
on his Asylum van I think he is
absolutely wrong I would probably
disagree with him on that as well thank
you Mr chair will the gentleman yield Mr
Correa yield of course my a few seconds
um
I just want to point out Mr Wolf
and all of our Witnesses here you you
may have a difference of opinion as to
how the United States should process our
Asylum applicants
but the notion that that difference of a
policy opinion would be the basis for
quote-unquote case closed that secretary
mayorkas is violating his duty is
preposterous and it is not any basis for
impeachment the general time is expired
I now recognize Mr Higgins for from
Louisiana for his uh five minutes
questions thank you Mr chairman
America's watching this or
listening to the commentary
you'd have to be living under a rock in
America to not recognize the
disintegration of our sovereignty at the
southern border over the last two years
got six million illegals process in some
manner
into our country one and a half million
known criminal run of godaways and and
the the board of law enforcement is so
overwhelmed estimates easily state
that that number is doubled of unknown
and uncounted criminal run of God of
ways
all told you talking about nine million
people
rolling into our country since President
Biden was inaugurated
secretary mayor orcas's failure is
difficult to calculate
the the impact Upon Our Country our
entire country
generational trauma
the man is brought Upon Our Country
my colleagues across the aisle have a
this is your Baghdad Bob moment
when you you witness clearly what the
truth is what everyone across the
country recognizes
as a disintegration of our Southern
border
and horrific impact upon our country and
you're drawn on and on about how great
things are
blame everything on Trump
good Lord for years
and yes a ranking member has a has a
right to introduce a government study to
the record but the insinuation was that
former secretary wolf served illegally
so I'm gonna give you an opportunity to
respond to that Mr Wolf
I know you very well did you serve
honorably and legally as Secretary of
Department of Homeland Security sir I
believe I did I was asked to serve as
that acting secretary by the president I
took my oath seriously I'm very proud of
the way that I led the department
lawyers can argue over the order of
succession about the acting secretary
before me but I think what's clear is
simply being confirmed does it make you
capable of doing the job
thank you for your response sir and I
apologize for on behalf of the committee
for that insinuation I think it was ugly
it was tainted by agenda
and over the course of the next several
months he'd perhaps they can develop a
new script and just attacking the Trump
administration because we're going to
expose what has happened to our country
over the last two years Mr Scott would
you explain to the committee in America
how secretary mayorkas has intentionally
shifted migrant numbers through the CBP
one app to promote the appearance of
decreasing illegal Crossings
as we discussed earlier the numbers that
are being reported publicly Focus
they're selective they've been focusing
on the Southwest border only and we need
to focus on total total encounters or
what ofo causes and admissibles if you
go into cpp.gov their website it's a
nightmare but you can slowly sort some
of this stuff out yes sir so so to focus
on a CBP one app is it true that does
virtually no parameters disqualifying an
applicant from applying for parole
through the CBP one app that is my
understanding that's my understanding as
well Mr Wolf in your opinion sir is an
increased use of the cbp-1 app for
parole application consistent with the
app's original purpose
no not the original purpose would you
clarify that for America please again it
was for forwarders it was for industry
on how to facilitate that that trade
across the border uh it was for boating
license it was for legal Commerce to
speed legal Commerce through through
through ports of Entry and yet now it's
being used for undocumented uh legally
identified as inadmissible illegal
migrants coming through our ports of
Entry using the CBP one app and they're
granted parole is that your
understanding that's my understanding of
how it's currently being utilized and
how would that be would you clarify how
that's in violation of the law
well again that's not how the CBP one
app was originally and again it's not
how you allow individuals to come in
parolling them in there's so many
different exemptions of using that CBP
one app if you can't access it they
allow you into the country and so it's
just a it's another smoke and mirrors of
how to bring in individuals again that
have no legal right to be into the
country whether you paroled them in or
put them into the Asylum system the end
result is all the same so we can talk
about the different ways the end result
is that they are released into American
communities and that is what's fueling
this crisis
thank you Mr Wolf Mr chairman my time
has expired this time has expired I now
recognize Mr magazine for his five
minutes question from Rhode Island by
the way
I I have to say I am getting sick and
tired of House Republicans
politicizing the Department of Homeland
Security
there are common sense bipartisan
actions that this committee could be
taking up to improve security along the
southern border but instead of advancing
smart policies to keep Americans safe
the Republicans have resorted to the
type of political theater and Biden
bashing that the American people are
sick of
we know there are challenges at the
border because poverty and political
instability are causing millions of
people to flee their home countries
but the notion
that President Biden or secretary
mayorkis are guilty of quote dereliction
of Duty are absurd President Biden and
secretary mayorkas have been proactive
in taking steps to protect our homeland
here are the facts
April 27 2021 just two months after
taking office secretary mayorkas
launched operation Sentinel to combat
criminal organizations smuggling
migrants across the border June 7th 2021
secretary mayorkas launched Joint Task
Force Alpha to crack down on trafficking
groups in Mexico and the northern
triangle countries of Guatemala El
Salvador and Honduras
November 2021 President Biden's
infrastructure Bill delivered 430
million dollars to Customs and Border
Protection above previously budgeted
levels for enhanced security at points
of Entry nearly every house Republican
voted no
December 15 2021 President Biden signed
executive order 14060 establishing the
U.S Council on transnational organized
crime with a focus on enhancing
operational and intelligence
capabilities to disrupt transnational
crime organizations
in 2022 the Biden Administration and
Congressional Democrats passed a
Homeland Security funding measure that
added 300 border patrol agents and 125
CBP officers every house Republican
voted no because it had Joe Biden's name
on it in 2023 secretary mayorkas
launched Operation Blue Lotus and
operation for Horsemen to disrupt
narcotics trafficking at in between
points of entry April 2023 the Biden
justice department unsealed charges
against 28 leaders of the Sinaloa cartel
engaged in drug trafficking and other
crimes the list goes on and on this is
just a sample of the actions that the
Administration has taken to improve
Security on the border but of course you
do not hear House Republicans talking
about any of this because it doesn't fit
their narrative the only dereliction of
Duty here is House Republicans wasting
time on political games instead of
focusing on the real problems that we
need to tackle to protect the Homeland
let's look again at the record House
Republicans introduced a measure to
impeach secretary mayorkas two years ago
when he had only been in office for six
months politics
a leader of this Committee in a
closed-door fundraiser months ago
announced that Republicans were going to
impeach the secretary and said quote get
the popcorn it's going to be fun the
gentleman yield that's not what I said I
want to correct the record I never use
the word impeachment and I'm tired of
this continual narrative falsely quoting
me I won't allow it Mr magazineer listen
continue your testimony
I'll continue listen another member of
this committee Ms Green just a few days
ago told the press that she voted on the
debt ceiling Bill only in exchange for a
quote beautiful dessert which is
impeachment so this has always been
about politics and political games and
the most important fact is this since
the expiration of President Trump's
title 42 policy illegal border crossings
are down 70 percent and even when you
include CBP one app appointments which
are legal
they're still down more than 60 percent
since the expiration of title 42 so
there are a lot of things that we could
be doing instead we're wasting our time
on theater now Mr Wolf
during your time running the Department
of Homeland Security were you ever
impeached
no no
during your time working at DHS in the
Trump Administration did you prevent all
unlawful entries into the United States
we worked every day to do that but did
you com did you prevent all unlawful
entries yes or no no okay well I'm
confused because I read Mr Higgins
articles of impeachment that he filed a
few days ago and in short they say that
secretary my orcas should be impeached
because he failed to maintain
operational control at the border
defined as the prevention of all illegal
entries into the United States so I
don't understand why didn't we impeach
the DHS director under the Trump
Administration or any prior
Administration if that's the standard
that warrants impeachment political
theater that's why that's all this is
and with that I yield back
gentleman youoms are recognized Mr
Bishop from North Carolina I think the
chairman and uh you know I think this is
interesting and it begins to ferret out
what really are uh is the key issue that
this Congress needs to focus on in
regards to the matter that's being
testified to and I appreciate the
witnesses who are here your your
professional and dispassionate you know
I don't I think almost no one is brazen
enough to anymore to deny that there's a
border crisis created by the Biden
Administration Secretary of our orchids
of order Chief Ortiz Ortiz admitted and
such on the way out the door FEMA
announced yesterday the distribution of
more than 290 million dollars in
Congressional funding to communities
receiving migrants you don't deploy FEMA
resources when there isn't a crisis
but the issue here and I agree it
shouldn't be political theater it's not
about policy differences can't be the
issue here is vindicating the rule of
law and the Constitutional role in
lawmaking power of congress
many claim the Trump indictment is about
the rule of law the ranking member says
appropriately policy differences are of
a different dimension and I agree with
that and the appropriate response for
Congress is different in in each case I
don't even think with all respect the
chairman that our Focus can be exactly
on dereliction in the full sense
articulated because dereliction is
willful or negligent and what we need to
focus on here is whether this is not a
case of negligence if it were the
implications would be different the
remedy would be different
incompetence in administering a federal
agency is Mal Administration
and the recourse falls to the people
alone
but intentional sabotage of the rule of
law is something entirely different it
is an affront to the separation of
powers to the institutional authority of
the Congress under the Constitution and
it invites another remedy and that is
impeachment
um secretary Wolf the ranking member
attacked actions by the Trump
Administration but you point you know
your statement in really elegant 10
pages covers a lot at the ground I I
urge people to look at it carefully you
point out that there what was you were
attacked for by the ranking member these
were exercises of authority specifically
granted to Congress take uh migrant
protection protocols remain in Mexico
you cite 235 b2c of the Ina in the case
of an alien described in subparagraph a
that somebody would have right otherwise
to um to Asylum claim of Asylum who's
arriving on land from a foreign
territory contiguous to the United
States the Attorney General May return
that alien to the that territory pending
and proceeding under section 1229a of of
this title so it's exactly what you did
whether somebody said you did it in the
exact way or if you want to challenge
Houston you're exercising an authority
um same thing with safe Third Country
agreements under Section 208 a2a and I
won't read all that
but
um here's what you point out the
violations of law several of these found
by federal district judges at this point
in time by The Catch and Release ignores
the mandate to detain or make them wait
an asylum African weight in Mexico
um that's been judged a judge by judge
Wetherill in Florida be unlawful the use
of notices what are they called ntr's Mr
Wolfe notices to report notices to
report so you don't even
have any formal commencement of removal
proceedings which a notice to appear
would be setting a date even though that
you never get to them they don't even do
it they just let them go with into yours
the exercise of authority to adjudicate
Asylum by by DHS officials maybe Mr
edlow you may have pointed this out in
your Testament instead instead of in the
Department of Justice where that power
is reserved
um the the interior non-enforcement
policy Mr Wolf you pointed out the
hundred day deportation freeze judge
Tipton said that was illegal subsequent
enforcement priorities established that
exempt 99 from the threat of deportation
secretary mayork is declaring the
illegal presence alone is not grounds
for removal more than a million in the
country subject to final removal orders
and they said they're not going to
remove them
um so
I'm just going to leave my last minute
to you Mr Wolf but I see what you're
doing what we're talking about is
intentional
sabotage of the rule of law as set by
Congress and that's a different ball
game it is different uh it's not just
about whether or not uh aliens illegal
aliens can claim Asylum as was talked
about here earlier as you indicated at
least in my written testimony there's
seven different instances where I
believe the law is not being Faithfully
executed uh to include the categorical
parole which was the last one there and
I didn't get you which is at ports of
Entry which is at the heart of all of
this you know to be uh to have Asylum
needs to be an urgent humanitarian
benefit or advantageous somehow to the
United States simply for only up to 360
000 individuals which is what they are
on track to do per year
violates the letter of the law it's very
clear final Point here is that it does
fall to Congress as well as these judges
fall to Congress through the impeachment
power to decide whether the law has been
intentionally flouted yield back
the gentleman yields I now recognize
Mr swalwell from California
I've heard the phrase rule of law and
accusations at the Biden Administration
is sabotaging the rule of law in the
title of this hearing is
secretary mayorkas's dereliction of Duty
On the Border crisis but I think in
contrast to that it's very interesting
to me that the chief witness that the
majority has called here Mr Wolf was
found on November 14 2020 by a federal
judge to quote not lawfully be serving
as acting secretary
not lawfully serving as acting secretary
so a lot of considerations and concerns
for my
colleague
across the aisle about the rule of law
but the witness that they called
served unlawfully is the acting
Secretary of Homeland Security where an
accusation of dereliction of Duty is
being made today
in addition to that again it's
interesting that this is the chief
witness that they've called today
because on September 17 2020
the unlawfully serving acting secretary
Mr Wolf
failed to honor his Congressional
subpoena
didn't show up
skip the hearing
so you have someone who's acting
unlawfully and somebody who Skips a
congressional subpoena and we're going
to be lectured by the majority about a
dereliction of Duty of the current
lawfully serving Senate confirmed
Secretary of Homeland Security I think
that's interesting and an important
perspective that we should have as we
consider what's going on at our Southern
border
Miss Acer
I want to speak with you
just about what is going on at the
southern border and if you were to think
about
the migrants who are fleeting the
northern triangle who
leave everything they know their family
their livelihood their culture
their homes their Community their
churches
and take the journey to America
do you believe that
if we were to find a way
is a Global Alliance
public-private Partnerships to help
invest in those countries in their
Economic Security and their physical
security
and stand up and support a rule of law
and go after corruption that that would
reduce the number of people who came to
the United States
absolutely
um I mean the reason that people are
coming here to seek protection is
because they're not being protected at
home by their countries there's a lot
more that the United States can do to
increase respect for human rights and
um to otherwise assist in making sure
that conditions allow people who can
stay safely in their home countries to
do so and I understand you know the the
counter to that will be well why would
we invest money there if we have needs
here and there's no doubt we have needs
here but if we're going to be spending
the money
anyway either enforcement of the Border
or taking care of people who come here
to me it just seems like a better
holistic investment to try and work
private sector public sector
non-profit ngos
in those countries to stand up as I said
economic and physical security
I also wanted to ask what effect do you
think it has Miss Acer when
my colleagues across the aisle and
Republicans say that we have open
borders and in fact the title of the
hearing today is open borders closed
case do you think if you are
south of our border and you're looking
for somewhere to go to keep your family
safe and to find some livelihood if you
hear people falsely declaring that the
borders open do you think that makes you
more or less likely to try and go to the
United States because you think the
border is open
I don't know how much migrants actually
listen to
um you know to to these hearings but um
but you're right in that I've heard
Mexican officials say they wished that
U.S politicians would actually stop
saying that the Border was open because
they thought that was really sending the
wrong message and sometimes
disinformation inaccurate information
does get into Facebook groups that many
migrants do follow
uh thank you Miss Acer and I think the
lesson here is that this issue is
complicated it involves human beings who
are leaving everything we've got our own
struggles in the United States and
clearly you know cannot take on you know
a consistent flow from the southern
border but it needs Solutions uh not
theater and I'm afraid that my
colleagues are interested in the crisis
but they're not interested in the
solutions and I yield back gentlemen
yields I now recognize Mr Jimenez from
Florida there's five minutes thank you
Mr chairman and and Miss Acer uh you
were quoted in the Baptist News global
uh referring to the end of title 42 and
you said that the dangers facing Asylum
Seekers are more cute than they were uh
years ago when the Trump Administration
started these policies and these
policies have contributed to a worsening
of the conditions that face migrants and
people seeking Asylum did you make that
statement
I don't remember my exact words but I
probably did okay thank you uh Mr Mr
Wolf
um
I believe like my colleagues that that I
don't believe that Mr majorca's is
incompetent I think that he is derelict
in his duty because I think everything
that he's done is actually done on
purpose do you share that view I do it's
this is this is by Design right and so
when
you know
I've been an administrator and when I've
made mistakes and I listen to my folks
and say hey why did that didn't that go
the way that I wanted it to I would
listen and say it and kind of change
things but Mr mayorkas kind of doubles
down and so when in the first days of
the Biden Administration a bunch of
policies that the Trump administration
had put in place in order to to secure
the Border were overturned and then
things started to go
South in a really big way
did do you do you know firsthand if if
people in the border that custom border
patrol agents actually advise Mr
Miracles that hey you need to reverse
these policies to stop this you know
this tidal wave that's uh coming into
the United States
again I wasn't there it's my
understanding that they did Chief Scott
was there uh in the border patrol
advising the Biden Administration so I'm
sure he can answer well Mr Scott can you
answer that question
yeah he was informed verbally he was
informed in writing I think it's
important for everybody to understand
everything fundamentally changed when I
worked for secretary wolf we had team
meetings we were asked for our input we
were told over your career what works
and what doesn't work on January 20th
2021 that all got shut off DHS the
secretary even went to the step of
shutting down the integrated teams of
career professionals that were brought
into DHS Ops to provide guidance our
input was no longer solicited and when
my team and I gave it unsolicited we
were basically put in a box they did not
want to know what we had to say they
made it very clear expedite processing
and find new ways to let migrants into
the U.S that was the only agenda exactly
which is on purpose
really circumventing U.S law 100 on
purpose scripted out and the secretary
is not incompetent no I know he's not
incompetent he's derelict without a
doubt uh Mr Wolf back to back to you
when you had the remaining Mexico policy
and people were told to remain in Mexico
and then they had their Asylum uh
hearings what percentage of those that
were seeking Asylum were actually
granted Asylum again it would have been
under that about 10 to 15 percent the
number that that Grant Asylum has been
holding for years now about 80 to 85
percent do not qualify and about 10 to
15 percent do qualify and we saw that
again under MPP as well all right so so
those are the people that actually
qualify to get into the United States
are granted uh you know paroled into the
United States uh given some kind of
legal status into your site because they
actually have a valid Asylum claim now
when you get rid of that and then you
you know and you allow them to come into
the United States and then you don't
well the law also says that if you're
seeking your Asylum you're supposed to
be detained until you're hearing correct
correct that's not happening right now
is it it is not okay so now you've got
all the people are coming into the
United States they're actually being
granted you know entry into the United
States so you're actually increasing the
number of migrants entering the United
States illegally
because they don't really have a valid
client assignment silent Claim by about
80 percent would you would you agree
with that number that sounds about right
okay and so we don't even know where
they are we don't know whether some of
them are being tracked some of them are
not being tracked we don't know where 85
000 children are at this point I
consider that to be a dereliction of
Duty children 85 000 we don't know where
they are
did that ever happen under the the Trump
Administration 85 000 no absolutely not
again you have a UA you have an
unaccompanied alien child crisis at the
moment 380 000 and so when you you know
if you happen to go to the the baseball
game tonight that will feel that that
feels National Stadium almost nine times
that's how many children that have come
across that border that have no parent
have no Guardian that have been smuggled
uh by these Mexican cartels at the
behest sometimes of their parents
because they know that if they get
across that border they will remain here
in the United States and it is a
terrible Journey you are subjecting them
to uh just horrific conditions and it
needs to end and the Democrats uh dare
to call what during the what happened
during the inter Trump Administration
inhumane I uh my time is up by yield
back
now recognize Mr Goldman of New York
thank you very much Mr chairman
um
our Witnesses were asked uh whether what
secretary mayorkas has done is
intentional
um obviously it's intentional
uh he's not doing things unintentionally
and he has testified before us and he
has acknowledged repeatedly uh that we
are dealing with a very difficult
situation at the border
uh I want to focus on uh go back to what
my colleague Mr swallow was focusing on
uh which is
um my my friend Mr Bishop's quote that
there is an intentional sabotage of the
rule of law
now we've heard a couple times today uh
that the GAO and a federal court found
that Mr Wolf was acting unlawfully
to my understanding that would be a
violation of the rule of law
but let's focus a little bit on some
policies and some efforts
Mr Jimenez mentioned uh that there are
children who cannot be found which
brings up of course the Trump
Administration
family separation policy
Mr Wolf when you were the chief of staff
to the Secretary of Homeland Security
isn't it true that you supported the
family separation policy I was at the
department from 2017 to the end of the
administration
well did you not according to an
inspector General's report uh urge the
counselor to the attorney general
to implement the family separation
policy to increase prosecution of family
unit parents and separate family units
no I don't believe no that's okay well I
want to introduce into the record this
in Factor General's report on family
separation which includes an email by
you to Gene Hamilton the counselor to
the attorney general so that email had a
number hold on consideration there was
no Direction there was no direct so
you're saying right here right now that
you did not support the family
separation that was not your testimony
that was not your question I'm asking it
right now is that your testimony we
implemented a number of policies in the
administration I agreed with President
Trump when he ended zero tolerance in
June June I believe of 2018. did you
absolutely support the family separation
policy because we had no we had no
family separation policy at the
department really
the department did not
no I'm happy to go through this all
right
Zero Tolerance policy let's talk about
this one sec one sec uh let's talk about
this because the facts are that more
than 5 000 children
were forcibly separated from their
parents at the border and the reason is
because the Department of Justice For
the First Time used Title VII United
States code section 1325 which makes it
a misdemeanor offense
to charge anyone crossing without uh
lawful with without papers Etc that had
never been used before because the only
point of that is to put parents who are
charged with that in jail where they
cannot actually
uh be be with their families
now a federal court in 2018
ended the family separation policy which
this court determined that there was
because the government's policy quote
shocks the conscience unquote and
violates the constitutional right to
family integrity
there are still children who were
separated at the border from their
parents who have not been found because
the zero tolerance policy which
ultimately ended up separating parents
and children did not create any
mechanism to account for that separation
in order to track the children
now that clearly as a judge said was a
violation of the rule of law an
intentional sabotage of the rule of law
let me go quickly to another one
according to a whistleblower complaint
by the former head of the Department's
intelligence branch
Mr Wolf ordered him to withhold an
intelligence notification on Russian
activities because it quote made the
president look bad
the Inspector General the office of
Inspector General investigated it
and found that the department did not
adequately follow its internal processes
and uh policy standards when editing and
dissemiting an intelligence product
regarding Russian interference with the
2020 presidential election and the
accurate acting secretary Mr Wolf
participated in that review process
Mr chairman I know my time is up I'd
like to introduce for the record that
inspector General's report which my
staff will give and I would like to note
that before we start attacking this
intentional sabotage of the rule of law
we ought to look in our own glass house
without objection uh so ordered I
recognize Mitch fluger from Texas for
his five minutes thank you Mr chairman
how rich
was that
uh Mr Wolf how many apprehensions
occurred in the Trump years combined I
mean just round numbers
all four years yeah I I don't have a
number for you
um the chief chief May chief
I don't have that number off the top of
my head to be honest but it was less
than a million a year and some years
less than 500 000. okay
um
how many since Biden has taken over
you have to define whether they're
arrested apprehensions apprehensions
would technically include encounters
there were over six million okay
known gotaways
known God away is over 1.5 million plus
or minus that's only the known okay uh
known or suspected terrorists uh there's
been about 200 I think there's 98 this
year and again those are just the ones
that are known to 200 since January 2021
and Mr Wolf you guys reported owner
suspected terrorists actually it took us
six months to get my orcas and the
president to actually report an under
suspected terrorists what's the combined
approximate total in the Trump years I
believe it was 11. 11.
how rich is that discussion that we just
heard about looking in a glass house
you know what the political theater here
is over 5 million apprehensions at our
Southern border
over 200 known or suspected terrorists
over a million and a half known gotaways
I have constituents who are currently
sitting in this Committee hearing right
now that live in West Texas
and these folks are dealing with the
unfunded mandate that my colleagues on
the other side of the aisle are calling
political theater
you're saying that 53 people that died
in a tractor trailer South of San
Antonio last summer is political theater
give me a break
this is insane that we continue to look
at this Administration anything less
than a complete abysmal failure Mr Wolf
it looks like you might have a reply or
something that that was from the
previous question uh why would you say
the previous question from the
congressman was probably false on all
fronts I think it's a naive view of of
the situation that occurred in 2018
children are separated from adults who
may or may not be their parents perhaps
they're their parents that are abusing
them this happens every day along the
border you need to visit the Border you
need to talk to border patrol to
actually understand the Border this
happens every day in the Biden
Administration this happens in the Trump
Administration Obama and it goes on and
on and on I'm sure the chief can tell
you more about that but this idea that
it only started in three weeks in 2018
it's just it's a false narrative well
isn't it true that the Obama
Administration actually started family
separation uh in all practicality Mr
Scott you served for four different
presidents uh both sides of the aisle
yeah correct I'm really offended by the
not not by you but the statement family
separation
DHS United States border patrol under
various different administrations
prosecute people for committing crimes
and we prosecute more people for
committing Crimes of the pop the
percentage of the total population as
the numbers go down over years we found
out consequences slow down the flow of
illegal immigration a consequence is a
prosecution that's what we were doing in
the field that happened way before the
Trump Administration some of you may be
familiar with operations streamline the
border patrol reported on it all the
time and that was misdemeanor
prosecution of illegal entry and it has
a direct result in improved border
security the track records there
multiple administrations Mr Scott when
did you serve the Biden Administration
what months for the byte Administration
from the day of inauguration until
August 14 2021 okay so approximately
eight months plus runs was secretary
mayorkas
briefed
on policy failures what are their
recommendations that were made to
secretary mayorkas and President Biden
from border patrol from Ice from Customs
from any of our DHS leaders I personally
participated in numerous conference
calls the secretary insulated himself a
lot but he had Representatives on those
calls and occasionally he was in those
calls himself and yes it was very clear
but the administration made it very
clear deterrence was no longer our
mission and we weren't even allowed to
talk about it the minute you talked
about trying to slow down the flow or
putting any kind of a deterrent
mechanism in place we were immediately
stymied so this is a willful
and complicit decision
to turn away from the policies from 2017
to 2020. and go a different direction
which have resulted in the numbers that
I previously said and they've been
advised and and there have been
recommendations made by yourself and
others that they have completely ignored
absolutely and they're just carrying out
their game plan that they said in the
campaign this is complete dereliction of
Duty I thank you gentlemen for your
service to this country Mr chairman the
dereliction that we see
from secretary mayorkas is unprecedented
and it has resulted in so many assaults
deaths and and drugs and Chaos in this
country thank you for holding this
hearing I yield back gentleman yields I
now recognize Mr Ivey from Maryland
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate that
I um
I wanted to say that I was uh when I
arrived on the hill this morning I was
surprised to find out that um
the committee had issued
a report
um is styled
causes costs and consequences in its
style is committee on homeland security
majority report
and it's I don't know around 55 pages
long and with this document lays out is
the Republican views with I haven't had
a chance to read it yet because you know
I just got it
um actually was waiting in my spot here
when I sat down to begin the hearings
that's the first I've saw it and then
they have a chance to go through it but
I want to say a couple things about it I
look forward to reading it and having a
chance to digest it I'm I'm deeply
disappointed that um
a majority report didn't give the
minority any opportunity not only to
review it but to respond to it and I
guess this isn't a formal report
but to the extent we're actually
looking to try and do things together to
work together to move the committee
forward together to address the issues
that are being addressed not only in
this hearing but in previous hearings
um
this kind of approach
doesn't work in fact it's
counterproductive to say the least uh
and I you know I understand you guys
have a view and you know some of the
points you have are different than ours
some of ours are different than yours
but if we're going to try and address
this together we actually have to work
together and it has to begin before the
hearing starts uh and you know what was
especially disappointing about this one
was I had a conversation with I won't
call a name but a member of the report
the Republican side
on the house floor last night with
respect to trying to move legislation in
this committee part of it came out of
the markup that we had a few weeks ago
where there was recognition I thought by
both sides that the Democrats had
offered some amendments that might make
sense for example with respect to the
the drones issue we you know we're told
when we went to visit the Border that
there was a 17-1 deficit we'd offered an
amendment to try and increase the number
of drones and funding for it
the Republicans didn't take any
amendments uh during the markup and
that's that's their prerogative but
there was a statement made at the time
well maybe we can move amendments that
you've offered that we find mutually
acceptable that are beneficial another
one for example was additional funding
for border patrol agents and there's
some Provisions in the bill that passed
but not all that we talked about to
provide additional funding hire more
agents retention by paying the more and
the like since we're losing agents and
it's harder to enforce the border with
fewer agents than more agents so we
talked about actual legislation to try
and address the problems that we're
talking about here and I was assured hey
yeah we can work together on this stuff
we got an oversight thing we got to do
tomorrow but you know
we can work together on getting
legislation done to it
I had no idea that the oversight thing I
knew the Witnesses were coming we got
the the testimony
just barely 48 hours in advance but at
least we did get it in advance
but this report is is you know a blind
side and I I think it's
um hopefully that's not
an indication of things to come but also
did remember at a previous hearing I
raised this issue as the New York Times
article that came out April 18th key
Republican tells donors he will pursue
impeachment of mayorkas now I don't need
to go through it again we put it in the
record previously
um
but basically it laid out a plan a five
phase plan quote unquote uh to uh set up
the Imports the impeachment of Mr
mayorkas and I was told that these were
misquotes and the like uh you know we're
really going to try and work together on
this we're going to follow the blah blah
blah in the hearing
this is on the record
and I get this
um you know I I
I I
understand that that both sides differ
as I mentioned before I you know my
first job here was 1987. on Capital
working for Congressman Conyers and I'm
sorry I missed earlier parts of the
meeting because I had votes in judiciary
but
can we actually try and address some of
these problems by working together I
know we've got different sides I
understand how hearings work you guys
get three Witnesses we get one that's
fine but
let's try and do things that we can we
can disagree without being disagreeable
and try and move our points forward I
think uh because this is the homeland
security committee our goal I think for
all of us is to try and do
what's best to help the American people
um and it's harder to do it when we're
working across purposes uh so with that
I yield back
gentleman yields back um the chair now
recognizes the gentleman from New York
Mr Garbarino thank you Mr chairman
Mr edlow what is the legal basis for
Asylum
uh the Ina section 208 sets out exactly
what Asylum is
is General economic hardship a legal
basis first oh a legal basis no it is
not
there are five recognized grounds of
Asylum is Journal violence or crime
along crime is General violence or crime
alone a legal base first basis it is not
congressman is political instability
alone a legal basis for Asylum not not
alone no
does filing an asylum claim after
entering illegally or improperly negate
the fact that the individual entered
illegally to begin with no it doesn't
however when someone comes into at the
Port of Entry claims credible fear has a
positive credible fear determination at
that point they are given the
opportunity to present an asylum claim
uh under Section 235 they are supposed
to be detained as we know that's that's
not been happening uh but they they are
able to stay in the country to file that
claim it is not they do not have legal
status in the country they are an asylum
applicant at that point Thank you are
you aware that the CBP and Troy Miller
CBP acting commissioner have recently
tweeted that most of those claiming
Asylum at the border don't qualify for
Asylum as economic migrants
I'm not aware of the Tweet but I would
agree with it
right
prior to the Biden Administration how
were the words
urgent humanitarian reasons and
significant public benefit in a parole
statute interpreted by DHS so I don't
think there's necessarily been a change
in the in the absolute in the actual
interpretation of the wording but where
I think there's a change is the sheer
volume of categorical parole programs
that we've seen I'm not going to sit
here and say that there were not some
categorical parole programs under the
Trump Administration I for the most part
would have liked to have seen them uh go
away I don't think that they're lawful
uh with the exception of maybe the Cuba
courts that allowed for the Cuban family
reunification uh the the remainder of
the programs probably should not have
been there however we saw maybe 20 30
000 people over the course of the four
years get paroled in under these types
of programs whereas now we're seeing
Mass parole where in the months prior to
them stopping parole given the Court
decisions and some other things we saw
months where there was over a hundred
thousand people paroled in that month so
the the sheer volume of parole numbers
is is astronomical now plus they're
doing it for specific countries whole
populations of those countries that they
have a sponsor here that that's not Case
by case that I don't see the they if
they have humanitarian needs to get here
they can come uh through other means uh
they can come to the border and ask for
credible fear as what we expected before
this is this is not an appropriate use
of the parole authorities
thank you very much a lot of numbers
going to talk about paroles are going up
um you know we've seen uh
numbers and migrants found dead on us
soil also Mr Scott CBP personal
Personnel have reported informally that
more than 1700 migrants have been found
dead on U.S soil and uh during this
administration's watch Biden my
orchestra's watch more than 500 were
found dead in fiscal year 2021 and
reportedly more than 800 found dead in
fiscal year 2022 the five years prior to
fiscal year 21 the number had not
exceeded 300 in any given year why is
the number of dead migrants found on our
soil increasing so much
because chaos kills people we've created
a chaotic border situation additionally
border patrol has a search and rescue
team that would normally just respond
and be out in remote desert areas
looking for people in advance and their
processing civil immigration cases so
we're leaving vast sections of Border
open and I would argue those numbers are
probably underreported I was down on the
border recently talking to some local
sheriffs and uh they're telling me that
they're finding bodies on ranches
they're things there are people dead
along the border they believe or have
just crossed that are not included in
cbp's numbers but chaos kills people and
that's what we've created on our border
I appreciate that and I have a 50
seconds left I know people run out of
time when they want to answer questions
so I want to yield the rest of my time
to Mr Wolf to if there's anything you
want to continue to say about uh you
know this hearing and what uh what
you've experienced I'd uh I'd appreciate
it
no again I I think uh what we did during
the Trump Administration is every day we
weren't perfect but every day we worked
to install policies and operations that
furthered secured that border that
actually upheld the rule of law day
after day after day some we got right
some we got wrong at the end of the day
I think if you look at the overall
evidence of of the past 27 months that
is not the case uh they have
specifically torn down policies and put
others in place that make that border
significantly less secure not only from
a humanitarian perspective but also from
a national security and a public safety
perspective as well thank you very much
I ran out of time so I yield back
gentlemen he owns the chair recognizes
Mr Clark
all right Mr Mr Garcia I'm sorry
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you to our Witnesses for for being here
today as well
um I want to just a couple notes I think
that first I just um
want to note that there's been a lot of
attacks of course on the of course on
the bite Administration and the work
that's happening on the border I think
that obviously as a reminder that
Democrats also want a safe and secure
border that's in the interest of
everyone
um in our country
um and I also want to note that there's
been a bemoaning that of course that
since the end of title 42 that the chaos
at the border that oftentimes many in
this committee were rooting for just
also did not happen and so once again
um it's very clear that we're getting
another political uh hearing another
distraction from the real issues that
are in front of our country I also want
to note that there's been once again a
repeating of things that have been
debunked by Witnesses by experts
repeated over and over in this committee
we've been ignoring the facts about
fentanyl we want to blame the opioid
epidemic on people that are seeking
their legal right to Asylum and not
actually on the failures of our
treatment system in the United States we
want to let folks want to feed a
narrative that if we just invade in
Mexico things will get better in this
country and all these things along with
false claims that our border is somehow
open the men and women of our department
of DHS are and our Partnerships with
ngos and in Mexico are doing their jobs
and again the border is not open and we
continue to do to do that work in this
country I also want to want to just
remind members of this committee there's
been a lot of back and forth on the
issues around family separation and I
want to give Ms Acer a chance to respond
to this we've heard a lot about family
separation under the Trump
Administration and specifically quite
frankly rewriting of what actually
happened out of History can you clarify
the actual differences between what
happened in the Trump Administration to
what's happening today
absolutely so the Trump Administration
initiated policies that they knew would
separate
children from their parents
the decision to start prosecuting
families for initial entries was done
with full knowledge of what the impact
would be I actually met mothers in
detention centers who had been separated
from their children had no idea where
they were or how to find them it was
heartbreaking as a parent
and um and I want to I want to note that
I think that um the differences between
what's happened during the Trump
Administration what's happening today
and the the point of actually the whole
process is completely different and so I
want to thank you for for that
clarification
um and and then and one other question
in this committee we've had members of
the majority uh work to defund programs
with ngos particularly around with
Catholic Charities Charities who's
trying to support legal Asylum uh which
is really uh shameful and and
um really counterproductive to our work
and our humanitarian work along the
border can can you explain why our
partnership with ngos that are providing
these services are so important to the
work that DHS does and and across the
border yeah absolutely those
Partnerships are critical globally
around the world
um as well as here at home
Faith leaders
Faith volunteers employees of Faith
organizations and other ngos you know
are inspiring
um you know those who are motivated by
their religions are trying to welcome
the stranger day in and day out through
their work
refugees around the world are welcomed
by faith-based and other organizations
that's critical to enable all the other
countries to be hosting refugees but
here at home we need more support for
the organizations that are working to
welcome refugees into our communities
there's also a disgraceful lack of
support for the organizations in Mexico
that are struggling to host refugees who
are now waiting to seek Asylum at our
ports of Entry thank you and finally I
just want to just note I know there's
been discussion about the the one app
application and I think one of the key
reasons that conditions have improved
and and really we're focused on legal
Pathways is because the CB1 app the CBP
one app
um after we all agree a difficult
rollout has actually made things a lot
better and so I just want to thank
um everyone that worked on that the
entire the department so many groups
that have been involved in the rollout
and now over a thousand migrants a day
are able to use that app to exercise
their legal right to Asylum which I
think is really important it is a legal
right even though some in the majority
choose to to not see it that way I yield
back thank you
the gentleman yields the chair
recognizes Ms Green of Georgia Thank you
Mr chairman
um it's interesting to me to listen to
some Democrats here on the committee uh
trying to harp on the very idea that Mr
Wolf is somehow illegitimate as the
former acting secretary we Republicans
here we are committed to searching for
answers as to why this Administration
continues to inflict catastrophic damage
to our country
and here I just want to remind you of a
few things that are very important to
understand not only is fentanyl
poisoning the number one cause of death
of Young Americans ages 18 to 49 nearly
83 000 Americans have died of opioid
poisonings since uh the year 2022 and
they die weekly in my district
96 individuals on the terrorist watch
list have been apprehended crime has
skyrocketed across the country and we're
missing 85 000 children 85 000 children
and while Democrats across the aisle on
this committee want to talk about
families being separated under the Trump
Administration I'd like to introduce for
the record Mr chairman a a letter uh to
custom it from Custom and Border
Protection
saying that the Biden Administration is
ending DNA testing familial DNA testing
as of that was at the end of May May
31st 2023 so when you talk about
separating children
separating children we have the Biden
Administration not even testing
testing who these adults and these
children are and I can't comprehend it
everyone in this room knows what an
amber alert is we all get them on our
phones right this is when a child has
been kidnapped
and we are so concerned in this country
about children who have been kidnapped
that we have something called an amber
alert notifying all of us that there is
a missing child
85 000 children missing migrant children
missing in the United States is the same
thing as 85 000 Amber Alerts
it's unbelievable
Mr Wolf many of the children
are brought to United States by coyotes
and human Smugglers
in your view
how is secretary Marcus responsible for
exasperating the unaccompanied children
humanitarian crisis
well it's not just one action it's uh
it's obviously a culmination of a
variety of different incentives uh it's
an incentive structure that has been
created over the past 27 months it
allows individuals to come into the
country and remain into the country when
you exempt uacs from title 42 that sends
a signal to the cartels and to everyone
else to smuggle as many children across
that border as humanly possible we know
they're going to stay in the United
States so when you make these
categorical pronouncements the cartels
are watching and they are paying
attention and just to key off on your
last Point not only did DNA testing
going to end about to end the vetting of
sponsors also ended at HHS under this
Administration no more vetting detailed
in-depth vetting of sponsors we also
increase vetting of other household
members we didn't know we didn't just
want to know who the sponsor was we
wanted to know other household members
and dive into those backgrounds that was
eliminated as well site visits not not
every home was visited but random site
visits to make sure that those children
were where they said they will be also
eliminated under this Administration so
the idea that somehow they're protecting
children because they needed to
facilitate the flow out of HHS
facilities quicker and quicker is is a
misnomer
unbelievable
Mr Scott it has been reported that many
minors at the Southwest border are in
fact related to adults with whom they
are traveling in fact some of them are
even recycled I can't even comprehend
using the term recycled when it comes to
children
and these kids are used Again by
different cartels and human Smugglers to
guarantee admission of family units and
your estimation has this exploitation of
minors exponentially expanded under the
mayorchis's policies
I believe it has and this is why every
one of those child recycling cases and
if you don't understand what that means
that means a child being teamed up with
a fake family over and over again so he
has to make that trip over and over
again because they're ins that gets them
to become a family unit and they get
into that categorical exemption to get
released every one of those cases was
discovered by an agent interviewing the
child and finding little cracks in the
story that takes time the agents don't
have that time today those conversations
are no longer going on at all they're
being they're being pumped through the
system like fast food commodities worse
than that now the DNA piece of it is
being shut down as well that was one of
the last tools to be able to quickly be
able to prove somebody was not related
that doesn't mean that there's not some
kind of a connection there but that gave
the agents a tool most people broke
immediately when they believed they were
going to be subjected to the DNA you
didn't even have to do it this
Administration knows they're putting
Children at Risk every day they're
enticing them to come to the country and
it defies common sense
thank you he should be impeached yields
the chair recognizes Miss Jackson Lee of
Texas
chairman thank you very much and let me
thank the distinguished ranking member
and chairman and my colleagues and
members and the witnesses every time you
put yourself forward we certainly thank
you very much
uh but this is a journey that I've taken
now for 28 years maybe a little shorter
and it never fails that whenever
Republican Administration is in my
Republican friends are in the majority
there is an enormous crisis
and the executive does nothing there is
no effort to write legislation there's
no effort to correct what any one of you
are saying
um and it is with all due respect and
admiration and friendship it's a broken
record
it is literally a broken record
before the late John McCain passed there
was a gang of eight who had an enormous
contribution to trying to do an overhaul
over immigration reform
and it was a party that is now in charge
of the house that blocked it
I worked with on this committee a
chairwoman by the name of Candace Miller
from Michigan
we worked on comprehensive immigration
reform measures to address the U.S
Mexico border which was blocked by the
Republican leadership at that time do
your homework
in years past we've written legislation
to provide the Border Personnel every
manner of support we could give them
so let me be very clear
the remain in Mexico problem uh program
was horrible because I went and visited
the squatter that the people were
sitting in there was nowhere for them to
go it was misery nothing was happening
the border wall you can get a nice
comment and quote I'll men and women at
the border are very nice people they
will give you quotes but it is well
known that most of fentanyl comes
through the United States citizens
through legal parts of entry and it is
also well known that even though you'll
say well that's because we need more
border roll
that the Border communities fight you
for the border wall not to have it
and Smugglers and others find other ways
as relates to the Asylum Cooperative
agreements we have agreements now with
Venezuela
Haiti cuber and Nicaragua and as it
relates to title 42 the Republicans
voted to end the public health
provision
that the president ended and by its very
essence you ended title 42.
let me quickly because I will be going
to one witness because all the other
Witnesses I know what you're going to
say but I do appreciate the work uh that
Miss um
that Miss Acer is doing so please be
ready for a question I'm trying to get
through
I heard the word impeachment I don't
know whether it was going in direction
of the my president the president of the
United States or whether it was going in
terms of secretary Marcus uh a immigrant
himself
who pulled himself up by the bootstraps
and has more commitment in his tiny
finger than what I would imagine some
who Advocate against him
and I make that generic
but secretary Marcus has done nothing
contrary to his boss
he is a member of the cabinet
and his boss wants America to be safe
the president of the United States
in every aspect of work that we can do
from The increased resources from adding
to the additional Personnel to creating
Pathways for people to parole in for
creating the app and the numbers have
gone down they surge up they go down it
depends upon movements of people
and so you have no more answers than
anyone else Mr Wolf you were in there
for a year or two years and I don't see
anything that you did that has brought
down anything that we're talking about
and this is not a personal statement
because I want to add and say I
appreciate your service to the nation
but everybody that's sitting there
that's criticizing had their opportunity
we've got to come together as a country
and stop scaring our constituents
because America is getting more diverse
and they are contributing to the economy
and to the culture of this nation
the world watches as to whether or not
we can make this experiment work they're
in awe of us
and they come because they're in our
because they're desperate because they
think this is the greatest country in
the world and it is and it's democracy
however challenged is still standing
it bothers me to masquerade I have this
question Mr chairman Astor industrian so
she can answer it I represent Catholic
Charities and many others
I've fought to get hostages back from
Russia
I have dealt with the crisis of
deportation family separated what does
it do to our very dedicated non-profits
who are innocent who have the
responsibility of taking care of people
in streets people are separated children
or separated people who are traveling
that you would assess them criminally
or find them so that they're so scared
that they cannot do the normal Humane
things for individuals who even may be
in here on a legal pathway coming into
the United States Mr chairman I asked
her Indulgence for her to be able to ask
that question just if you could make
make your answer short to the Miss
Jackson Lee's already over her time so
I'll allow it I'll allow it and just
make your answer as quick as possible no
basis for the secretary to be impeached
but go right ahead
it's reprehensible
um not only does it punish people for
acting on their humanitarian values it
also punishes them for acting on their
faith beliefs as well and it's totally
counterproductive I mean here in America
we need our faith-based organizations we
need our communities to step up and be
part of the solution and many Americans
want to do that and are doing that as we
speak thank you thank you gentlelady
yields I now recognize Mr leloda for uh
his five minutes uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you sir for your
leadership and bringing this committee
together on this hearing and for your
efforts to make my constituents life
safer for securing the Southwest border
I appreciate the witnesses and your
expertise uh being here uh I represent
the first congressional district of New
York the western edge of my district is
about an hour or so east of New York
City and over the past several weeks my
constituents have heard how New York
City's Sanctuary City policies coupled
of course with our countries a
non-secure and wide open Southwest
border have overwhelmed New York City's
resources previously meant for the
homeless for folks suffering from
substance abuse and veterans in need and
given the influx of migrants who are
attracted to New York City because of
those Sanctuary City policies the city
can no longer handle the influx of those
migrants in the response mayor New York
city mayor Adams is now attempting to
sending those same migrants who are
attracted by those Sanctuary City
policies two Suburban counties
throughout the state who have expressly
rejected those Sanctuary City policies
and Mr Wolf that at least my first
question sir can you please explain what
sort of costs such as monetary Personnel
Public Safety are imposed on States
cities and counties in dealing with the
current crisis of the Southwest border
sure there's a variety of different
costs you know all of the children that
we've talked about going to public
education systems English is usually not
their first language and so that's going
to strain public education systems in
every community that they go into
certainly the ones that they go to in a
large amount Health Systems Public
Safety Systems you now have Public
Safety officers Law Enforcement Officers
having to deal with additional crimes
and additional uh incidents particularly
along the border that I've talked to
sheriffs that are overwhelmed because of
what's going on and then we talk about
the money that DHS is sending to ngos
right billions of dollars I'd say
millions of dollars being sent to ngos
for a crisis that they created that
they're now using taxpayer dollars to
send to try to solve the crisis
um and so there's a lot of different
costs and you know that American
taxpayers bear what if anything sir can
you say about the cost on public safety
with a whole slew of unvetted uh young
adult migrants excuse me adult migrants
they're being shipped to Suburban
counties what can you say as far as what
Public Safety costs I think there's a
variety of different you know ways if
you if you talk to Law Enforcement
Officers along the border they're
dealing with crimes and they're dealing
with incidents that they've never had to
deal with before when you talk of of
military aged males individuals coming
over that are a certain age that are not
being vetted right we talk about 1.5
million godaways these are individuals
that obviously don't want to interact
with Law Enforcement Officers for a very
specific reason they're here to do bad
things or we talk about a hundred
thousand Afghans that weren't properly
vetted and we've seen and there's been
reports of of crimes and incidents that
are occurring on that front so I think
there's a variety of different things
that you can point to that says if the
process was followed correctly and and
individuals are vetted as they should be
some of this should not have occurred
4 billion New York City has said that it
will spend 4 billion dollars next year
caring for and housing the illegal alien
population that has come to New York
City because of its Sanctuary City
policies eight billion taxes on track to
spend more than 8 billion on operation
Lone Star doing the job that secretary
mayorkas won't do securing the Southwest
border and another question for you Mr
Wolf how do these massive expenditures
affect the cities and states who are
forced to pay them and is it fair for
New York and Texas law-abiding taxpayers
to have to suffer the burden that the
open border and the sanctuary City
policy no no none of this is fair none
of this should be occurring but this is
what happens when the federal government
refuses to do its job we've never seen
this before as I testified it's in my
oral and written every Administration
has progressively tried to make
improvements along that border I would
argue that some administrations did more
than others but every administration at
least in my lifetime has done that this
is the first that has not only taken one
or two steps back we've probably taken
five to ten steps backwards and so
you're gonna that's got to be picked up
by someone and it's different states
along the border and it's different
municipalities cities and officials that
have to pick up the slack they have to
protect their communities
thank you I appreciate you being here
today with your expertise and your
experience Mr chairman I yield back
gentleman yields back uh I now recognize
Miss Clark
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
everyone I just wanted to correct the
record of uh my colleague Mr lalota
these immigrants had no choice and where
they ended up in the in this nation they
crossed the southern border yes but it
was governors of state and of the states
of Texas and Florida that put these
individuals on buses directed to New
York City so having said that
um we are currently as my colleague rep
Korea demonstrated in his line of
questioning witnessing an unprecedented
uh human migration movement around the
world of individuals seeking Refuge
safety and Economic Opportunity
individuals are fleeing economic
instability governmental corruption and
persecution violence climate change has
ravaged food and water supplies in their
homes of origin and this has been
evident in Many Nations within the
Western Hemisphere and especially in the
Caribbean in the island nation of Haiti
it's individuals have been enduring far
more dangerous means and methods to
escape and to seek Refuge
um
here in the United States this is not
just a challenge for the United States
but a global Challenge and we must step
up to the plate to do our part so my
first question uh my only question is to
you Miss Acer would you agree that
there's an unprecedented movement of
vulnerable people in the Americas and
worldwide and can you speak about how
that is affecting our border and how our
government should work with regional
Partners to address this challenge
yeah absolutely there's been a
significant increase in people fleeing
fleeing from playing in search of
protection in the Americas in recent
years there's also been a shift with
increasing numbers fleeing from
Nicaragua Venezuela and Cuba I'm sure
some of you know for example about the
Crackdown on political opposition and
Faith groups in Nicaragua forcing many
people to to flee that country for
example people who have fled from
Venezuela are facing restrictions in
some of the countries that they have
been in and they are seeking seeking
safety and stability as well so there's
been major regional uh shifts but
there's a lot that we can be doing and
doing more of in the region
um incredibly important is to continue
to support and support as best we can
the front line countries that are
actually hosting the vast majority of
refugees I mentioned for example that
countries in Latin America and the
Caribbean are hosting six out of the
seven million Venezuelans who left their
country it's certainly in the U.S
interest to continue to support those
efforts critically important that we now
have a commitment to start long overdue
resettlement from the region from the
Americas that needs to be absolutely
stepped up and you mentioned the plight
of Haitians who are facing such extreme
dangers that the UN and the U.N Refugee
agency said that it is too dangerous for
people to be returned to Haiti right now
so
um parole for example has been an
incredible Lifeline for some people from
Haiti but the parole processes are not
as accessible as they should be for many
people facing dire risks and the numbers
are too small the there's really no way
often for Haitians to actually flee in
search of Refuge so thank you so much
for everything that that some of you
have been doing I would really encourage
bipartisan support uh you know for
um the for the programs that are helping
refugees around the world for the
expansion of refugee resettlement from
the region and for the these very legal
parole initiatives and I'd like to uh
thank you for for the work that you're
doing and uh Mr chairman without
objection I'd like to enter this report
led by the Haitian Bridge alliance with
input from Miss Acer and human rights
first which documents their observations
on the southern border following the end
of title 22. without objections and I'd
also like to just say that uh for those
who are Christians in the room
um you know I just find it uh very uh I
guess disorienting that we we see
suffering around us as a nation one of
the wealthiest in in the hemisphere and
that today we sit here not looking for
Solutions but creating problems uh Jesus
Christ was a refugee I yield back
the general lady yields I now recognize
Mr D Esposito of New York for his five
minutes well thank you Mr chairman
and uh thank you to our panel I thank
you for those who have have served this
country and for all the work that you
can continue to do
I first want to start with um I guess a
simple question to each of you and ask
who's Secretary mayorkis was appointed
by
the president
our current president President Biden
thank you Mr Scott President Biden
President Biden
President Biden thank you
just wanted to make that clear
so I guess my first question is going to
be to uh Mr Scott
um
there was a story that in response to a
mounted uh border patrol agent in Del
Rio Texas Secretary mayorkas
had stated about the images that were
shared that they quote those images
painfully conjured up the worst elements
of our nation's ongoing battle against
systemic racism
now I asked that question because
on my multiple visits to the border and
speaking to Customs and Border Patrol
agents just recently I visited JFK
Airport which is just blocks from my
district I'm a retired NYPD detective
and I I feel that
boots on the ground having conversations
speaking cop the cop you really get an
understanding of of how people feel
so
how do border patrol agents who have
legitimately made it their life's work
to secure our border feel when their
so-called leader the Secretary of
Homeland Security
rewards their hard work by slandering
them as systemically racist
it's a kick in the gut and I'd like to
point out that that followed the
secretary going on national TV and
declaring that the Border was Secure so
his credibility was already challenged
with that second kick in the gut really
damaged morale beyond anything that
could be imagined
thank you
and I think what was important you said
in your opening statement that this is
not about policy it's about his legal
Duty and the fact that he took an oath
and I said when he was here that you
take an oath to defend and protect the
Constitution you protect our nation's
borders and that's what he should be
doing from the moment he wakes up in the
morning to the moment he closes his eyes
in his bed he should be working every
second to protect this great nation
I think it's clear from today's hearing
that secretary mayorkas has been
derelict in his duties to secure the
Homeland but also derelict in his
ability to protect CBP agents and DHS
employees both border patrol Chief Ortiz
and National border patrol Council vice
president Chris Cabrera recently told
Congress that 17. 1 7. CBP Personnel
committed suicide in 2022 the highest
total in over a decade
how has mayorcas's unprecedented border
crisis affected the lives and families
of our border patrol agents
I'm hesitant to blame the Border crisis
on any specific death or suicide but I
want people to think about this
if every law enforcement agency out
there has to make decisions he misses
birthdays he misses soccer games just
because of the schedules they work
there's a lot of family tension but
historically that agent that officer has
been able to go home and say unprotected
America I'm doing this so that our kids
can have a better life this
Administration makes border patrol
agents and many CBP officers feel like
Smugglers they no longer have that
intrinsic mission that they can justify
to their spouse to their kids of why
they miss those important events I
believe that has cascading effects in
many areas and can potentially be a
factor in the suicide and I agree with
you and I think that
someone who came from law enforcement
there's nothing more important than
knowing that your leader or so-called
leader has your back and when you go to
work every day and realize that the
control at the border is no longer in
your control but now in the control
of cartels
it makes your life more difficult
17 CBP suicides in one year is
absolutely intolerable
do you believe that secretary mayorkas
has been derelict in his handing of the
crisis among the border patrol agents
and I don't I don't just mean the
policies along the border but the way
that he's treating the men and women who
put on that uniform the men and women
who stand that line the men and women
who want to protect our points of Entry
I believe he's derelict and I'll go back
to the horse Patrol incident in Del Rio
you know everybody focuses on the first
allegation that was approved wrong very
very quickly yet behind the scenes
secretary mayorka still moved to take
disciplinary action against those agents
for doing nothing but trying to prevent
the illegal entry of aliens into this
country right in front of them which is
their job when he disciplined those
agents that Cinder that sent a
resounding message throughout the entire
Workforce that not only did he not have
your back he was out for you I agree
listen when so-called leaders and we've
seen it in the state where I'm from when
you take the handcuffs from the police
when you take the handcuffs from their
Bell out and actually handcuffed the
police and give criminals and in this
case cartels more resources
things need to change and I appreciate
your service Mr chairman I yield back
gentleman yields I now recognize Mr
Menendez for his questioning gentleman's
from New Jersey thank you Mr chairman
and um
you know it's as I think others have
alluded to this um this is a bit of a
frustrating day we had secretary
mayorkas here in front of this committee
and I think there is maybe only a
handful of questions asked during that
during that hearing from colleagues
across the side the opportunity to
really engage with the secretary that
you're now looking to remove from office
and there wasn't a lot of appetite to
engage in that honest conversation and
then today we get this report you know
shortly before this meeting and it took
me no time to go through it because this
is supposed to be an investigation a
report looking into what's happening at
our border but throughout it the using
sources like Fox News The Heritage
Foundation the Washington examiner the
center for immigration studies
an extreme Think Tank the daily signal
all Outlets that reaffirm what
Republicans want to make the Border seem
instead of doing a real investigation
thoughtful about how we can improve the
situation at the border which Democrats
have engaged in when we've talked with
uh Chief Ortiz he's talked about how the
funding is working that they have the
funding that they need but they need to
continue to work on recruitment he even
spoke about how morale is high what you
don't hear from folks in this room
because I feel like there there's an
attempt to paint a picture that is
politically beneficial for folks my
colleagues who I do have immense amount
of respect but they've already made the
decision about what they want this
report to be and you look at the sources
throughout you look at how static
statistics are framed and it's all done
to get to the destination that they had
already decided they want to arrive on
um and to me you know that's that's
extremely problematic along with other
things throughout this and again we only
had minutes to review and I was just in
a TNI
committee on the FAA reauthorization but
there's a section called empowering a
vast NGO Network to facilitate illegal
immigration we're talking about groups
like Catholic Charities
we're not talking about some Sinister
operation that the federal government is
working with ngos with to move illegal
aliens across that's not what's
happening we're talking about people who
are trying to help other human beings
organizations like the Catholic
Charities and here in this report where
we're making it seem Sinister also just
to be clear this is not just about the
Border
there's a section rolling back of DACA
people who have lived through their
entire lives rolling back DACA is one of
the solutions that that we should give
consideration to so this is not just
about the board this is about you know
an extreme policy towards the Border
towards immigration based on you know
you know
non-objective sources that that Eed this
reports move in a way where it got to
the destination I think a lot of people
wanted to get to that's disappointing
um I do think people ask us and look to
us to get to real solutions
um the last thing I'll say is I think
there has been an immense amount of talk
about uh 85 000 unaccompanied minors who
are lost I don't believe any of the
Witnesses are with HHS or have worked at
HHS but as I understand it the situation
is that they Place calls
um to these families to the sponsors of
these children and there was 85 000
unanswered calls
I understand that as a fact but there's
no one here from HHS
um that can speak to that but it's
something that I think would course
correct a lot of the conversation that's
been had today obviously if there's any
migrant children that are unaccounted
for that's something we want to work on
that's absolutely something we want to
work on but when you when you talk about
the dereliction when you talk about all
the things you try to cast upon this
Administration upon this particular
secretary
you're doing so in a dishonest way
and that's just a disappointing thing
for me because I do have so much respect
for our public servants my colleagues
the staff of this committee
um but this is this is not the direction
we should be heading this is not the
result if you want to take a real look
at the border
um this is this is really to me just
political messaging now yield back
gentlemen yields I now recognize Miss
Lee from Florida
thank you Mr chairman for having this
important hearing and to our Witnesses
for being here today it is undeniable
that we have a national security and a
humanitarian crisis at our Southern
border under secretary mayorkas's
leadership at the Department of Homeland
Security the number of illegal boarding
border crossings has reached a record
high and many of these Crossings are
unaccompanied children these children
are vulnerable to trafficking
exploitation and other forms of abuse
just last month we saw a migrant child
who arrived in Safety Harbor near my
district without a parent or Guardian
who died in federal custody
tragedies like these are avoidable and
preventable and today we've heard
testimony about decisions that are being
made at the Department of Homeland
Security that have facilitated this
crisis Mr Wolf I'd like to return
specifically to a line of earlier
testimony you were providing about the
decisions of secretary mayorkas to
suspend certain policies that have had
the net effect of endangering these
unaccompanied children who are coming
across our border specifically you
touched on a couple of things
that the vetting of sponsors and
household members for these children is
not being done appropriately and that
site visits have been eliminated would
you tell us please a little bit more
about those safety protocols and the
significance of them not being done
effectively sure once children come
across that border and border patrol
apprehends them they're quickly
transferred over to HHS facilities where
they stay until they're able to find a
sponsor and the sponsor comes picks them
up and they do that what we were finding
was that individuals coming to pick them
up we didn't know who they were and the
background checks and the type of
vetting that was done was not sufficient
we wanted to make sure that we were
protecting those Miners and that they
were going into households that they
wouldn't be traffic they wouldn't be
further trafficked in but again this
Administration for a variety of
different reasons I think we could only
guess decided to reduce the amount of
vetting on those sponsors that come and
pick them up but it's not only the
sponsor it's the again it's the others
in that household so it's not enough to
to do that background check on on one
adult but there's five other adults in
that household you want to know who they
are as well again they have reduced
those vetting requirements site visits
as well
and my my guess and it's it's a guess is
because early on in this Administration
the number of children coming across
that border in such astronomically High
numbers was backing up HHS facilities
there were too many children in there
and so the quickest way to get children
out of those facilities is to reduce the
amount of time they're in the facility
which is to say reduce the amount of
vetting because vetting does take time
we need to make sure that we know who
those individuals are that are picking
up these children but if you reduce that
amount of vetting and you reduce the
time then the children can go through
those facilities quicker there's not
amount there's not lines and they're not
backing up
Mr Wolf is it correct to say that those
protocols those measures that you used
to implement with checking the people
checking the sponsors checking the
people who are living in that home
verifying that the sites are safe and
conducting that ongoing monitoring of
the sites was that an important part of
ensuring that we're keeping these
unaccompanied minors safe when they're
here in our country well absolutely from
the HHS uh perspective Chief Scott
talked about it earlier DNA testing is
something that border patrol could do so
we actually tried to find it early in
the system as early in the system as
humanly possible which is when they
cross that border and they go before
that border patrol officer to do that
questioning that line of questioning and
again as you reduce that you're taking
more and more protections away from
trying to protect these children and
trying to reduce the amount of
trafficking that's going on thank you
and on that subject Mr Scott would you
please return to the subject of DNA
testing and tell us what role what what
role does DNA testing why is it
important in our efforts to combat human
trafficking and the exploitation of
children
it's very important for the simple
reason you're trying to identify people
and you're trying to make sure people's
stories actually match I left out of my
my statement earlier in the Ina it
mandates that we fingerprint and
photograph anybody over 14 years of age
it's silent below but counsel has
determined that you need reasonable uh
articulated facts above and beyond to do
the fingerprinting and photographing of
minors so most children because again
border patrol doesn't have time right
now to get those facts aren't
fingerprinted or photographed
so there's no historic data to look at
to figure out if the child is being
recycled or not then on top of that the
massive flow so the DNA testing the real
actual rapid testing at the stations and
just the threat of that could take a
potential two or three hour interview
and make it into minutes because people
broke left and right that it's not
really my kid because we would tell them
you're going to be prosecuted you can
tell me the truth now but now they don't
have the ability to do the threat and
then if someone sticks to their story
they don't have the ability to actually
identify that there is no actual
biological connection between these
people more children will be trafficked
more children are at risk thank you sir
Mr chairman I yield back General lady
yields I now recognize Mr
well we have Miss Titus here I recognize
Miss Titus from Nevada
well thank you Mr chairman I apologize
for being late I was in a markup but it
doesn't sound like I miss much because
it's the same old points uh being
hammered over and over again for
political reasons and not trying to
really look for a solution also this
Committee just continues to look at this
one topic if you're talking about
dereliction of Duty perhaps we should be
looking at some of the other aspects of
Homeland Security like cyber security
that's such a major issue a real
immigration reform or a Home
domestic terrorism those are all part of
our charge and not looking at those I
think is a dereliction of Duty uh in my
district we have a lot of mixed status
families we have somebody who is a
dreamer somebody who's TPS somebody
who's a citizen somebody who has no
papers and somebody who doesn't even
know what they are so that's five
problems all in one I'd like to ask you
Ms Acer if you would uh comment a little
bit about the TPS aspect of that because
uh it was just announced that the
president was going to extend TPS for El
Salvador Honduras Nicaragua and Nepal
could can you talk about how that helps
with Humane immigration or accommodation
of people here we've got 6 000 TPS
holders from Mostly from El Salvador in
southern Nevada so I'd just like to hear
more about where that is yeah TPS is
critical
um it is you know a life-saving
protection for people from places that
are too dangerous or for other reasons
people cannot be returned to so it's a
lifesaver it could be improved and there
needs to be access for people to
eventually after a certain number of
years to really be able to stabilize
their families
um to be able to bring their kids to
safety and you know ultimately to to get
onto a path to citizenship
well I know that the former president
ended TPS
I mean for some of these countries there
were some people who had been here 20
years
established a family
had a job paying taxes and then suddenly
that's yanked away in there and uh
they're sent back so maybe you could
help us with some ways that we could
actually put forward to improve the
system as you mentioned
I'd happy to be suggested suggest
changes and I think one of the most
important ones is that people can
actually get onto a path to citizenship
at some point and also to bring their
families together we also need to make
sure to be using redesignation Authority
because sometimes situation in a country
triggers a need for TPS and then you
know time can change again time goes on
but actually the situation is even worse
so that TPS needs to be redesignated to
make sure to protect people well thank
you also I think you were on the ground
when title 42 was lifted you know there
were some that were just so anxious to
see these people Rush across the border
chaos sending down troops I don't know
if they thought there was going to be
some confrontation but of course it
didn't happen and the numbers have
actually gone down would you talk about
that a little bit for us yeah so we were
there including on the the first day
after title 42 we were in Matamoros we
also were in Reynosa everywhere we went
you know we met Asylum Seekers we spoke
to I think hundreds of Asylum Seekers I
was part of a delegation with the
Haitian Bridge Alliance and other ngos
as well as just on our own with our own
researcher and you people were
struggling to follow the process for
seeking Asylum at ports of Entry we were
asked so many questions about the CBP
one app people were trying to use it
couldn't get an appointment uh there are
tons of glitches as you've all heard
some people with dark skin were having
trouble actually being able to register
for the system uh people many people
don't have phones Asylum Seekers we
spoke to many families who had been
robbed of their phones or didn't have
one to begin with in some cases there
was a need for internet access you know
people were walking around struggling
trying to to get sufficient internet
access to be able to actually use the
app and the other problem is that the
number of appointments are really small
when you look across the border and you
have silent some Seekers who've been
waiting and waiting you know for weeks
and months and it's in the U.S interest
for people to actually go to Ports of
entry and seek Asylum there if possible
um and
um I stress also though that it's so
important for there to be access to
Asylum for people who can't use and
access CBP one not everyone can they're
people who don't speak languages that
are used by the system and as I
mentioned they're people without phones
we've got to make sure that our ports of
Entry are operational and that there's
ways for people who are seeking Asylum
who don't have to have cbp1 appointments
to be able to do so
um and who can't get them and Asylum
Seekers from Mexico they're Asylum
Seekers from Mexico who have been
waiting and waiting it's in the next
door country but can't get in at one of
the ports of Entry thank you and I yield
back Mr chairman
General lady yields I now recognize Mr
strong
from Alabama thank you Mr chairman
um Mr Wolf under U.S law the secretary
of the Department of Homeland Security
is and I quote charged with a duty to
control and guard the boundaries and
borders of the U.S against illegal entry
of aliens close quote Mr Wolf would it
be safe to say that it is a
responsibility of this role to be
apprised of strategies tactics and
methods being employed to exploit our
borders absolutely
uh would you also say that a great deal
of time at DHS has devoted solely
debriefing uh and keeping the secretary
informed on such matters
yes there are numerous ways the
secretary stays informed uh about a
number of things going on at the border
thank you on several occasions this year
uh when he was has appeared before
Congress secretary marorkas has
testified that he was unfamiliar with
some of the tactics being employed by
cartels at the southern border Mr Wolf
in what circumstance would you say it's
understandable or acceptable for the
Secretary of Department of Homeland
Security to be unaware of what is
happening at the border
in that particular instance I can't
imagine how he's not aware of of those
tactics is it a total failure at every
level
again I can't imagine why he would not
know that uh just by visiting the Border
talking to border patrol agents and
understanding that frankly it's just
common knowledge uh that those are the
tactics I would think so also uh Mr Wolf
Mr Scott Mr inlow whoever's comfortable
secretary moorecus has had more than two
years to observe the failure of his
policies and either change course or
resign if not allowed to by the by
President Biden he has done the opposite
doubling down on those policies and
implementing new unlawful programs uh
does this strike you as uh someone
helplessly responding to a crisis or
someone intent on policies that caused
the crisis
I believe he's very committed to his
policies and uh I don't mean to be out
of order but I'd like to comment on your
last question for the secretary please
do I put in writing as the chief of the
border patrol of what those tactics were
in a memo that went through commissioner
acting commissioner Troy Miller and it
was addressed to secretary mayorkas it's
clearly outlined and that was while I
was still chief of border patrol thank
you Mr Scott I appreciate that and I
want to come back to you with this
question uh why would the Department of
Homeland Security secretary oppose the
construction of more border wall uh more
border wall system especially when
border patrol agents routinely say it's
an important part of the tool kit
because the president campaigned on no
more border wall thank you Mr Scott
since you're here and I want to thank
you again for coming back before so I
know I've met you several times during
the Trump Administration uh
you look the big thing that I saw
whenever you were there
um border patrol apprehended processed
and by Ice Air returned these illegal
aliens to the country of their origin
what message did this send when you were
there to those seeking to enter America
illegally
it that is a huge deterrent a couple of
things happened I think and we keep
talking about godaways but what people
aren't really understanding is that
every godaway and then every person
released into the United States does
exactly what you would do they call home
and they tell their family and friends
where they're at they check in their
friends and family hear that that
message gets out when we put p and then
more come when we put people on
airplanes and they show up back in the
Home Country after expending all these
resources they have horror stories about
the trip unfortunately but they chose
that trip but they tell those stories
and then they see them back home and
that has a huge deterrent effect that
actually saves people's lives because
people choose to stay where they're at
and make things better as opposed to put
themselves in the cartel's hands thank
you Mr Wolf secretary Milwaukee's has
apparently turned off all the fiber
optic sensors embedded in the Border
fence that was built during the Trump
Administration to allow the border
patrol to detect when and where people
are trying to either climb the fence
which is not easy or cut through the
fence with welding equipment equipment
do you believe secretary marorkas has
played a role in directing the
Department of Homeland Security to Halt
the completion of Lights uh
post-construction and or turn off the
fiber optic sensors embedded in existing
fences so I can't think of a reason why
you would
decommission or turn off capabilities
that are already installed the border
wall system is is much more than just
that physical infrastructure
lights camera roads physical access all
the things that border patrol agents
need to do their job why you would turn
those off it's beyond me I can't even
think of a reason why you would do that
thank you and with eight seconds left I
know it was mentioned that illegals
don't have internet access I want to let
everybody know that there's counties in
Alabama that don't have internet access
also we need to work in America to solve
that problem thank you I yield back
gentlemen neon's back I now recognize Mr
Ezell
from Mississippi thank you Mr chairman
fentanyl poisoning is now the largest
leading cause of death for Americans 18
to 49. as a 42-year law enforcement
officer and a sheriff I saw the
devastating effects of young teenagers
and young adults dying as a result of
this and it's heartbreaking
the death toll continues to climb
the rising uh Power of the Mexican
cartels continue to grow and uh this
low-cost manufacturing of a drug is uh
terrible to this open border
Mr Scott you believe the current
fentanyl crisis is the consequences of
Mr mayorka's open board policy I believe
that in part it really is and I want to
highlight some misinformation people
keep talking about seizures as if it was
the total more fentanyl is seized at the
ports of Entry than in between the ports
of Entry but it's because CBP officers
are there doing a fantastic job they're
ready to greet everybody every day we're
leaving hundreds of miles of Border open
every single day no one patrolling it
but yet border patrol is still catching
fentanyl between the ports of Entry the
metric needs to be how much is available
in our cities and there's no shortage
and your role as border patrol Chief how
you have seen cartels tell us how you've
seen the cartels capitalize on the
border crisis and use the surges for
migrants to
smuggle their narcotics so historically
the cartels have used any distraction
they can and honestly a lot of people
have a hard time picturing this so just
think of sports you fake a play to the
right you run the real play to the left
that's what the cartels have done
they've always done it they've always
tried to do it when you've seen in El
Paso a young child I think of the last
one was basically like a several month
old child being dropped over the fence
and plain sight of cameras where they
know it's going to be viewed that's
because they know agents are going to
prioritize taking care of that baby and
they can push something else through
they now unfortunately we've given them
millions of distractions we've given
them right now what 35
000 distract 3 500 distractions a day
that the border patrols have to go deal
with so that they can bring anything
they want and it's lowered their
overhead it's lowered their risk and
it's a direct impact on the ability to
get narcotics in cities in the U.S and
other threats
thank you Mr Wolf last year 850 migrants
died at the border this is the highest
ever recorded the average under the
Trump Administration was 280.
if this is the case why does the abide
Administration continue to tout their
immigration policies as safe Humane and
orderly
I I'm not sure I have a question or an
answer for you Congressman uh the amount
of deaths that are increasing in that
desert and along that River are a factor
of the the amount of people coming
across the border we're seeing a huge
Spike right so we were at 10 000 a day
for a long time we're at 7 000 a day
we're still at 3 500 to 4 000 a day
right you only have to go back to
secretary Jay Johnson under the Obama
Administration that said a thousand a
day it's a bad day for the border patrol
we're in crisis mode we're still at 3
500. so this idea that somehow we have
retracted from 10 and that's that we
should Pat everyone ourselves on the bat
and say good job you're still losing the
ball game in a big way
um and so I I think that is uh something
we need to look at absolutely thank you
Mr Wolf I keep thinking about these
words safe Humane and orderly uh do you
believe that secretary mayorkas has been
honest with the American people
I I don't not only on those words but uh
you know when you talk about the border
secure operational control he talks
about putting people in expedited
removal he knows what that means the
staff of this committee knows what that
means none of those individuals likely
be removed all they have to do is claim
Asylum uh and they are pulled out of
expedited removal so he uses terms like
these for the American people to try to
explain away what's going on along that
border but those that work in the
department know immigration they they
know something else and so if you're a
border patrol agent and you hear these
words and you're saying you know your
political leadership is saying look I'm
removing all these folks under expedited
removal you know that's not the case
Mr Scott could you add anything to that
I would agree to that a hundred percent
the words very rarely match the actions
it
I'll just leave it that yeah
thank you Mr chairman I yield back
the gentleman yields are now recognized
Mr burkine from Oklahoma
thank you Mr chairman
so secretary my workers sworn oath to
support and defend the constitute
Constitution against all enemies both
foreign and domestic
he swore that oath to defend against all
enemies foreign and domestic to the
Constitution he did not swear an oath to
support this administration's policies
and by this majority memberships count
secretary my orcas has chosen to ignore
or refuse to enforce over 10 different
federal laws and this is a dereliction
of Duty and a violation of his oath the
rule of law which is a term that's
thrown around often times by members of
Congress it means that nobody's above
the law means no member of the Congress
it means no member of the Judiciary it
means no Secretary of Homeland Security
the rule of law matters what the
Constitution what federal law dictate
matter speaking about the rule of law
Margaret Thatcher once said any any
country or government which wants to
proceed towards tyranny starts to
undermine legal rights and undermine the
law President JFK John F Kennedy once
said certain other societies May respect
the the rule of force of law we respect
rule of force we respect the rule of law
Barack Obama former president said one
of the challenges of a democratic
government is making sure that even the
midst of emergencies and passions we
make sure that the rule of law prevailed
dot dot dot prevail
so I want to talk about the federal law
and I want to talk about the areas that
have been violated section 103 A5 of the
immigration and nationality act says
that he speaking of my Orchestra in his
position currently shall have the power
and duty to control and guard the
boundaries and borders of the United
States against illegal entry of aliens
Mr Scott how is my orcas violating this
he's not even trying so all you have to
do is look at his words any public
statement he continually talks about
creating Pathways for more migrants to
come to the United States CBP one app is
nothing more than an invitation
worldwide without any immigration
documents or any right to come to the
United States you've never heard him
once support any initiative that border
patrol put out that actually allows them
to increase their situational awareness
and be able to stop the flow he even
disciplined agents for trying to stop
the flow Mr Wolf I'm going to read
something tell this to you on May 10th
the reporter immigration analyst Todd
Benjamin reported ahead of the
expiration of title 42 that Mexican
immigration officials were informing him
they were coordinating with DHS
Personnel on the other side of the
border to move illegal aliens from the
Mexico side of the Rio Grande to the
American side in other words Mexican DHS
officials were helping illegal aliens
cross into the United States this would
violate section 274 of the ACT we just
cited which prohibits aiding and
abetting illegal immigration or helping
someone enter the country illegally what
are your thoughts on this
I I think it's concerning
um look border patrol agents are in a
difficult position when they see
hundreds of thousands of folks coming
across that River they want to make sure
that they're safe and secure but at the
same time they should not be
facilitating that either so my guess is
those decisions uh had some buy-off from
leadership somewhere in the department
they would have to
yes they would have to no one would take
that upon their Authority without my
annoyed about it Mr Wolf section 212 of
the immigration and nationality act also
just mention beforehand
says that parole can only be granted on
a case-by-case by basis a temporary
basis for an urgent humanitarian reason
significant public benefit
how is my orcas's mass release of
illegal aliens into the interior
violating this U.S law and where is he
deriving the authority to violate the
clear language of the statute so we use
that Authority very differently urgent
humanitarian need is if someone needs to
come into the United States for a
medical procedure of some kind you allow
them in and then obviously you remove
them as well for a significant public
benefit you want to parole someone in to
probably testify at a criminal trial you
parole them in and then and then you ask
them to leave what you don't do is
parole 360
000 individuals a year from four
different nationalities regardless of
who you are regardless of what you do
the simple fact that you come from that
country that you're somehow granted
parole I think it's interesting that
those individuals are not putting being
put in the Asylum system
so the administration is either
signaling that they don't qualify for
Asylum or or or the system's broken
which we know it to be instead they're
parolling them in which is a different
set of benefits uh again it's a little
bit of a shell game that they're that
they're using is he adhering to federal
law I don't believe he is no and last
question Mr Scott article 4 section 4
guarantees to every state a republican
form of government and to protect those
States against Invasion five million
people more than the population of
Oklahoma coming in illegally under the
body Administration do you believe that
he is violating the Constitution Article
4 section 4.
I believe what we have at the Southwest
border currently is an invasion for a
slight different reason than most people
understand
that the illegal aliens themselves may
not be the Invader but they are being
used by a cartel that has nation-state
power people don't understand that the
power of the cartel in Mexico the
influence they have on the government
the Weaponry they have is equivalent to
many many countries and that cartel is
using this massive illegal immigration
every day to invade our country the
sovereignty of it and depose real
threats and through fentanyl alone which
is only one of the things they smuggle
they've killed more Americans than most
wars it's an invasion
thank you Mr chairman
gentleman yields I now recognize Mr
Crane from Arizona
thank you Mr chairman I find it
interesting that many of my colleagues
continue to talk about how Republicans
screaming about open borders is causing
this Invasion I want to ask a couple of
the panelists um were any of you guys
paying attention back in the
presidential campaign
um back in September 2019 uh when uh
then candidate Joe Biden said We're a
nation who says if you want to flee and
you're freeing oppression you should
come Mr Wolf did you hear that I did Mr
Scott did you hear that yes I did Mr
edlow I'll be honest Congressman I
wasn't paying attention at that point
darn it Mr edlow you broke the streak
Miss Acer how about yourself
words but certainly I've heard President
Biden speak positively about the
importance of seeking Asylum
what do you what do you think Mr Wolf
what kind of message do you think that
sends to people that might want a better
life
well I think it sends the message that
the borders are open now is the time to
come if I'm elected there's going to be
a new security regime along those
borders and I think that we saw the
results of that absolutely absolutely I
want to I want to double tap on that
because that is a massive part of the
causation here next you know I just want
to I just I find it interesting as I sit
in this chamber and I continue to hear
political theater political theater this
is all political theater
I want to go through some of the
political theater that we continue to
hear 4.8 million encounters at the
Southwest border 1.3 million known
gotaways 69 individuals just this year
on the terrorist watch list
238 fentanyl deaths in 2022. does that
sound like political theater to you guys
does not no it's not how about this
border Town's only Hospital running out
of resources on the brink of collapse
caring for migrants um Arizona in the
state that I represent does that sound
like political theater
that's the problem these are real lives
these are real issues this is real
infrastructure that is being overrun
this isn't political theater the reason
we continue to scream about it is
because our colleagues don't really seem
to care
and quite honestly the American people
sends us congressmen and women
representatives to represent them up
here in Washington DC and they are
filling the causation
of these policies they are filling the
causation of this plan
I want to also go into the political
theater of what the American taxpayer
feels
182 billion dollars billion dollars
reported to cover the costs and curve
from the presence of illegal aliens
that's
1156 dollars every year per taxpayer is
that political theater
do people feel that Mr Wolf
I believe they do feel that and I think
uh the most concerning thing is it's all
avoidable absolutely what about you Mr
Scott do you think that that did
American tax papers uh taxpayers filled
out
spent most of my career along the
Southwest border I'd work with Texas a
lot right now and they're double paying
for border security it's a resounding
yes and it's completely avoidable
absolutely how about five suspected
MS-13 gang members in U.S illegally
charged with murder and death of
Maryland 15 year old is that political
Theater California MS-13 gang member
accused of 10 year olds torture and
murder how about that political theater
how about how about this one five MS-13
gang members who killed Virginia
teenagers sentenced to life in prison
Washington Post more political theater
that we have to continue to scream about
because nobody on the other side is
listening this Administration continues
to ignore it you know one of the most
interesting things because I'm the last
I'm the last person that gets to
question anybody Mr Scott I heard you
testifying how many how many
administrations did you uh serve under
sir I was in the border patrol for about
six I was in leadership positions in
five right and you know you said
something that really struck me as
somebody who's been in the military
before you said that when you actually
and members of your team actually
brought up deterrence on phone calls
with this secretary you guys were shut
down immediately correct face-to-face
transition teams phone calls the entire
time that seems really odd sir it
doesn't sound as if this secretary
wanted to hear what could stop these 71
000 fentanyl deaths what could stop
these hospitals from getting overrun
what could stop these children from
getting murdered by MS-13 gang members
does it no we were prevented from
talking about border security or threats
at all and the last thing I want to say
Miss Acer I know you spent a lot of your
life
trying to help migrants right I read I
read your bio and I think a lot of
Americans can identify with that and
even appreciate it what they don't
appreciate is that your concern and Care
does not seem to extend to them
whatsoever
that's a problem and ma'am I want to ask
you one question
has your organization ever taken money
from the Soros Foundation
excuse me the Soros Foundation have you
ever yes we've received money from
multiple multiple foundations over many
years
you know how much money you guys have
taken from the Soros Foundation no I do
not know how much money we've taken in
from any foundation and I just am really
troubled if you're somehow picking on
one particular Foundation there's a long
history of thesaurus Foundation being
targeted for anti-semitic reasons that
has nothing to do ma'am with why why we
have an issue with it everybody knows
that George Soros is a globalist and
uses his money to often destroy the very
things that protect Americans our way of
life and our freedom that's exactly why
I ask you the question thank you I yield
back you know minions we have a member
an at-large member who has uh and we of
course sought unanimous consent at the
beginning to allow her to be here miss
De La Cruz you are recognized from Texas
thank you Mr chair uh for hosting this
meeting today and for allowing me to
wave on today to this important hearing
um I'm congresswoman Monica De La Cruz
and I'm here on behalf of my
constituents
um on behalf of the RGV border patrol
sector the brave men and women who serve
and defend this kind country you know
Texas 15 is right along the border in
South Texas it includes Macallan Texas
and over the last several years I have
seen
um the other side of the aisle the
current Administration demonize our
hard-working border patrol agents not
only demonize them but crippled them
with lack of resources not only on the
technology side but lack of resources
from being able to put current policies
in place and do their job which is to
protect this country but yet they get up
day after day and still go to their work
long hours and when I think about those
brave men and women I not only think
about them but I think about their
spouses and their children because the
stories that you don't hear are the
stories about how these men and women
when they go and pick up children who've
been abandoned because the cartels they
just leave these children on lands
children at the age of one at the age of
two of three
our border patrol men and women are
carrying these babies they're helping
women to give birth on the banks
the reason that I came today and asked
to be waived on because is because they
need a voice they need a voice to stand
up for them to show them that the people
in Congress care
well at least some of them because when
we look at this room I can see people on
the other side of the aisle are not here
are not here to see what the crisis is
at our borders to see our national
security
and how there is a lack of security due
to this Administration that being said
I want to say that uh Chief Scott you
were here under the previous
administration and my understanding from
speaking to uh my uh my friends in
Border Patrol in the RGV sector is that
you put together many processes and put
them in place in order to be able to
facilitate the um the immigrants coming
through and how to how to properly put
them through the through the borders
that being said there were several
various or there were various executive
orders under the previous administration
that seemed to work can you tell me how
the executive orders from the previous
administration and the executive orders
from this Administration have changed
during the last Administration in the
Trump Administration gets labeled with a
lot of this but under secretary Wolf's
guidance and others we put together
integrated teams and we had a simple
question put in front of us literally
every week we had to go back to the
White House and give it answers what can
we do to secure the border and Protect
America
in all the EOS that went in place MPP
the Asylum Cooperative agreements I was
sitting at border patrol agents to
countries down south left and right to
build relationships with them and just
simply get them to enforce their own
laws it was all about protecting America
and then on January 2021 everything
switched every one of those policies
that actually showed progress and
improved and protected America was
replaced with messages that said speed
up the processing as fast as you can
we're not into the deterrence business
anymore and we need to find new ways to
get more migrants into the United States
so do policies work
policies do work rhetoric Works short
time but policies and actions work long
term and I believe Mr edlow is really a
key into some of those policies and he
may have and before I go to you let me
ask you one last question uh Mr Scott
how many people did you personally
parole into this country so why I was
chief of the border patrol that
Authority was delegated to sector Chiefs
and not to try to get out of it but
because that's how much we cared about
it there's 20 sector Chiefs Nationwide
so when I was a sector Chief in a year I
think the most paroles I ever did was
about 10 and the things that people are
missing is there was a very in-depth
threat assessment done with every each
and every one of those individuals there
was a plan to keep track of them and
then when whatever the reason was was
done we physically made sure the person
was removed the United States consistent
with the law that being said how does
that compare with the current
Administration and the amount of uh
paroles that are LED into this country
we were using it consistent with the law
Case by case individual determination
from my understanding the way it's being
used now is just a blanket way to get
people out of stations avoid the Optics
of people backed up in border patrol
stations and I think that's where this
is a real concern is it all goes to
Optics when it's convenient to the Biden
Administration with that I yield back
gentle lady yields I uh now recognize
the ranking member for his closing
comments
uh thank you Mr chairman um and you know
it's you know we've had the opportunity
to engage in a dialogue about what we
hope we can do together and you know for
me I think today was challenging because
it feels a move away from working
together across the aisle on a lot of
the challenges that we have to face
including the Border uh it's a it's a
move away from trying to come to a
comprehensive approach to immigration
reform
um the fact that the report was issued
this morning without consultation with
with minority with the staff
um I want to be clear about one thing
secretary mayorkis has not violated the
law
he and the Department of Homeland
Security have been working to secure the
border every day I've been to the Border
twice since January I went with a
delegation of Democrats from Homeland
Security so we have an interest in
dealing with this issue directly and
availing ourselves of the opportunities
to deal with people directly who are at
the front lines so we're not running
from this issue but we are trying to
work at it in a constructive
manner if you talk about the
administration secretary Marcus has
increased efforts to go after Smugglers
we talk about additional legal Pathways
to enter the United States but that
actually hurts the cartels and Smugglers
business model so by creating
constructive actual avenues for people
to come here legally it undermines the
the what they're trying to what the
cartels are trying to do at the border
and the numbers are what they are
encounters at the border are down we
don't all have to agree with the
administration's policies but the facts
show that they are in fact effective I
do hope that a few sure we can have real
substantive discussions on the threats
facing our nation is critically
important that we do so I hope we can do
so
um under different circumstances and I
look forward to doing that work because
we are here to create solutions for all
of our constituents I look forward to
those days I yield back
gentleman yields and uh recognize myself
for a few closing comments first I just
want to reiterate
um that we're looking at
a cause and effect
and the cause is policies that were were
working you can look at the numbers that
were coming in
and those policies were thrown away
migrants listened to the president about
granting Asylum and all this stuff
granting uh
you know permission to just basically
come into the country and they and they
came and they tested the system and
those who got here made phone calls back
home
and uh the wave of people started
this notion that a migration crisis has
occurred
and we're responding to it is is wrong
we created a migration crisis by
creating an incentive for people to come
here we opened our border people tested
it and they called home and now more are
coming
um
not hurricanes not earthquakes not
changes to our immigration law not
changes to the budget at CBP not changes
to the number of border patrol agents
what changed were policies and it has
created a mass migration wave from 160
countries of people coming to the United
States
tragically the drug cartels have taken
advantage of this
They seized on the opportunity to use
people
to pay them up to 13 billion dollars
transferred to some of the most heinous
people we've seen the images we've seen
the videos of the burning human corpses
they've executed
yet
we're trying to find
you know some excuse for this the excuse
the cause and the effect is policies and
a mass wave and cartels who are
manipulating the situation
add to that
the tactics and strategy of the cartel
to overwhelm Customs and Border Patrol
with mass waves of people
thinning of the line in order to process
freeze up the cartels to come right
across the border in their carpet shoe
wearing backpacks full of Fentanyl and
we've seen the piles of the backpacks in
Arizona and Texas
the effects Americans are more unsafe
period
and all you have to do is look at that
little baby from France who was visiting
the United States crawling around on a
VRBO carpet
and encountered fentanyl left from
someone before
that baby died
how many Americans take their kids to
the hotel
how many Americans go to a VRBO and say
you
you don't know if you're safe
in the United States of America
because of the policies of this
Administration and and this secretary
we know that rapists and murderers have
been released and that's not counting
the population of the godaways
we've got percentages in the folks that
have turned themselves in
why would you be a godaway by the way if
you know you're if you're just here to
get in for economic purposes or even
Asylum why just turn yourself in and
you'll get released into the country why
would you be a godaway
1.5 million of them in the United States
now what percentage of that 1.5 million
are murderers or rapists or drug dealers
or cartel members
Mr mayorkus can't answer that question
we're going to have Mr America's back
here but
no one can answer that question
Americans are unsafe because of this
open border National Security 200 plus
terrorists versus 11. that tells you
that the terrorists are trying harder
and harder to get into this country
because they know the policy that the
the door is open
National Security this chart is
incredible
you look at the past several years
there's not much statistical difference
in those years but suddenly in this year
look at the Chinese Nationals pouring
into this country and we have reports
from secretary Chiefs saying they're pla
associated
they're taking a a lesson from the
Russians who infiltrated Ukraine before
they invaded now it's not to say that
the Chinese are going to invade the
United States but if we were to defend
Taiwan think about what those people
might become
it's interesting to think about but Mr
mayorkas can't guarantee us
what they are they're just being
released into the United States
that's a national security issue
migrants separated I I you know 80 we're
talking 85 000. I understand the phone
call system that means there were some
whatever the number is and probably in
the thousands and oh by the way the New
York Times not known and in the report
not not a Fox News not a Newsmax the New
York Times went and found some of those
people found they were stacked in homes
as much as 20 and were being used in
forced labor
should never happen in America it
happened because mayorkas's decision a
dereliction of Duty as far as I'm
concerned waved the
um background checks on those
individuals unconscionable
it's been discussed the financial costs
too not just the human cost an effect
and it will cost us it is costing us
your health insurance is going up
because of the uncompensated Care at the
ER period
why because seven plus million people
Mr mayork has broke the law we've had
Witnesses cite the law
read the law
and describe the methodologies which
he's either subverting it or breaking it
he's refused to abide by at least two
court orders
fact
he made it lawful to enter the country
in lawful Pathways that don't exist in
the law that's breaking the law that's
violating the law
and he clearly lied to Congress
chip Roy showed him the definition of
operational control
he said yes according to that definition
we have operational control of the
border and then in the Senate after
Ortiz made his comment he admitted no
one's ever had control by that
definition admitting that he lied when
he was in front of the committee with
chip Roy
a Secretary of Homeland Security a
secretary of any Department in our
government cannot come to the United
States Congress and lie to Congress
under oath period
that is a dereliction of Duty whether
you like the fact that we're you know
helping people who are in need he lied
to Congress
that's unacceptable and oh by the way
I'm we went back and searched the record
all the pounding on Mr Wolf here which
we'll tell you something if if you're
not Defending Your Own guy and just
beating up on the witness maybe you
don't have a leg to stand on but we went
back and looked at your record sir and
we can't find anywhere where you claim
to have had
operational control at least you didn't
lie
um he admitted his own incompetence
in the Senate he said he did not
understand the strategies of the cartels
now Merrick Garland the Attorney General
said yes that's the strategy of the
cartels the Attorney General gets it
the Secretary of Homeland Security
doesn't understand the strategy of the
cartel he's been asked to confront to
protect Americans
that's admitting incompetence
I want to correct the record on a few
things too
Asylum
is is the heart of our country trying to
help people in need I get it appropriate
abuse of Asylum laws
for a political purpose is wrong
an asylum is not granted to people if
you read the law just because they're
coming from a corrupt government or from
a crime-ridden area
or poverty Asylum is granted when a
government is pursuing an individual
the U.N Charter is very clear when a
refugee is seeking Asylum and they go
into another country that country is
supposed to take care of them and not
pass them on to another country that's
in the United Nations Charter why is
this happening all over the Central
America
and why are we accepting that that's
okay we signed the U.N Charter they
signed the U.N Charter let's enforce it
there's insinuations that because we
want to see the rule of law in place
that we're somehow anti-migrant
or anti-cherity
when I ran my health care company
I I built the not-for-profit for a lot
of reasons I wanted to hire Physicians
to join my company that had a heart to
serve people so we had a not-for-profit
and we paid those doctors expenses so
that they could do foreign trips and we
could run free clinics I I want to serve
people
but the government doesn't get to pick
where my charity goes
the government doesn't get to decide
that I Mark Greene's taxpayer dollars
are going to go for taking care of my
maybe I want to give my charity
to Gold Star families
the the family members of dead Americans
who fought for this country maybe that's
where I want my charity to go maybe I
you know want to plant trees
and save the environment
best vacuum cleaner for CO2 on the
planet is a tree
but I I'm having to pay taxes that the
president gets to decide where where
that charity goes no
been an accusation today that the GOP
has done nothing we just passed a border
security bill that addresses all these
issues
Mr Acer you said that we shouldn't say
that the border is open
because it might incentivize more people
to come I think that's what the
implication of what you were saying
I couldn't agree more
that's why we're having the migration
crisis is we opened the border the
president said it in his campaign people
come and they call and now they're
coming into the country
um I agree it creates an incentive and
you apparently do too
immigration is is not our committee
here's another thing well maybe I
misunderstood you but that's what I
thought you said but immigration
is not our committee we don't get to
solve the immigration problems people
here today have talked about hey we got
to fix immigration yeah we got to fix
immigration but if you create more of an
incentive for people to come they're
going to come you have to secure the
board of first you secure the Border
then we'll fix immigration
I I couldn't agree more on that
ngos not all ngos are bad not all ngos
are good there are some that are doing
great things and there are some that are
incentivizing the migration that is
harming people
and there are some incident
incentivizing people to break the law
and that's just period
and just because you're looking into
ngos it doesn't mean that you're
anti-ngo it means you want people taken
care of appropriately
we've talked about the CBP one app and
and the shell game that that is
we've been you know accused of not
addressing other issues like cyber we we
have many other subcommittees that are
taking actions on Cyber and Maritime
security and other things that stuff's
all going on you can't make the
accusation that we're just here
Prosecuting Mr mayorkas
Congress has both an oversight
requirement an oversight obligation as
much as it has a passing laws obligation
and oversighting this crisis is our duty
and we're not going to shirk that Duty
and it is revealing that Democrats today
spent far more time baselessly attacking
Mr Wolf than defending secretary
mayorkas in his policies
if you examine the facts there is no no
defense for his dereliction of Duty
this is just the beginning
of a lot of hearings
fulfilling that Duty for oversight
we will get to the bottom of what's
going on at our Southern border we will
characterize the costs to the American
people
and we will inform them and hopefully
inform the president
My Hope Is that the president is unaware
of all this and that maybe he'll do the
right thing
and fire a guy who has lied to Congress
broken the laws and facilitated this
Mass migration that's resulted in the
harm both of Americans of the migrants
I want to thank the witnesses for their
valuable testimony today
and all of our members for their
questions as I said at the beginning
we're going to disagree we did
but um that's what this is all about
it's the sausage making as they say
the members of the subcommittee the
committee may have some additional
questions for the witnesses and we would
ask that the witnesses respond to those
in writing persuant to committee rule 7D
the hearing record will be held open for
10 days for such purposes
without objection the committee stands
adjourned
thank you
right
now
he shouldn't say that
again
[Music]
I see you kind of jogging back here
aren't you so I don't even know
um
foreign